This is Jocko podcast number 40 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo,
good evening.
And the last podcast that we did,
I went a little long with the book.
The book was brave men
by a guy named Ernie Pyle and there was just some incredible writing in there
that I just went deep with.
I read it all
and so we had to postpone the Q and a so that's okay.
Gave us some time here to gives us some time here to go a little deep on some Q
and.
A.
This is podcast number 40 by the way,
40 weeks straight who wants some 40 weeks straight is where we're at.
And that's apparently that's the battle rhythm here.
We put out podcasts and we do it weekly and we've been doing it for 40 straight
weeks and I did that.
And it's not always easy,
you know,
cause if you think about the times,
think about the times when you're not doing anything
well when you're not doing anything or when I would normally not be doing
anything for 40 weeks I've been doing something,
I've been reading,
I've been prepping,
I've been researching.
So 40 weeks is legit and I'm,
I'm stoked that we're at number 40.
Me Too.
And now we get to talk about some questions from the interwebs.
So thanks to everybody for giving us the,
uh,
awesome questions through Twitter,
through Facebook.
It's pretty much where they come from.
Twitter and Facebook,
I guess.
I get a couple emails.
I get texts too from like some of my,
some of my buddies in the seal teams,
they'll hit me up with a question here and there.
A lot of times I just respond to them,
keep it real.
Um,
sometimes I
use them.
Sure.
But anyways,
yeah,
let's get to it.
Let's do it.
Okay.
[inaudible] first question from the vault.
From the vault.
I've got a lot of questions.
I've got a big vote.
Got a big vote.
And so I was just trying to go through and make sure there wasn't any questions
or just reviewing questions that might be good that I missed the first time
around.
So this one right here is from the volts from the old school to all Western one
that you always intended to maybe revisit.
Yes.
We go revisiting it.
Let the revisit begin
started Jujitsu,
thanks to you.
Any tips for complimentary exercises,
especially for nonathletic civilian?
What's the hardest stage of your end?
What's the hardest stage of your Jujitsu journey?
Yeah,
and that's actually,
that's actually,
it was two questions combined them into one cause they're,
they're kind of a similar and,
okay.
So do you just do one thing that's cool.
Bunch of Jujitsu is it's a,
it's a very well rounded physical activity,
right?
You've got to have flexibility,
you've got to have strength,
you've got to have endurance.
You got to be able to recover quickly.
Went from fatigue.
Yes.
You got to have some agility.
Speed,
balance,
coordination.
Yeah.
Proprioception.
Do you know what proprioception is?
[inaudible] it's,
it's knowing where your body is in space.
Sure.
It's,
it's a talent that gymnast have very well.
Yes,
yes.
Um,
maybe a dancer has rule,
they know where their body is in space.
Yeah.
And Jujitsu demands that you know where your body is at all times.
So that's the stuff that you need to work on.
All this,
all those things.
Cause Jujitsu is a unique test of all those things.
It's a test of your strike that's a test of your flexibility to test of your
endurance.
It's a test of your ability to recover.
It's a test of your agility.
It's a test of your speed of your coordination is a test of all those things.
And so that makes it,
that makes it,
um,
yeah,
a really good sport to practice in my opinion.
So,
uh,
what do you need to do?
What you need to do,
um,
to,
to train them and you need to trade all those things.
You know?
So for flexibility,
I like,
I personally like to MobilityWOD I think that's excellent.
You know,
but you don't get some kind of stretching protocol,
uh,
gymnastics type smooth movements.
There's gymnastic bodies,
which is a ridiculous Lee good
protocol.
You can go on.
It's an internet thing.
Gymnastics,
[inaudible] dot com and what is that like a workout?
Yeah,
it's a flexibility.
it's,
it's hardcore.
It's hardcore.
Um,
but that's really good.
Or you know,
you'll get your flexible,
you get all kinds of stuff from that.
But so you gotta be flexible.
You've got to work on your flexibility.
So what are you gonna do?
Like I said,
you're going to do mobility,
water,
some kind of stretching protocol.
So you get limber,
you've got to work on your strengths are,
what do you do?
Work on strength,
Olympic lifting,
what does that clean and jerk snatches,
uh,
that brings in things like cleans by themselves,
you know,
uh,
presses and hang queens and all that.
And then on top of that for strength,
you also have the simple movements,
the dead lift,
the squat,
the front squat,
the overhead squat,
and also first strength.
You can go back to gymnastics again,
go back to those gymnastics movements.
And basic calisthenics,
pullups pushups,
dips,
squats,
flutter,
kicks,
that whole nine yards.
Now you got to have endurance,
right?
So what do you do for endurance?
You could see where this is heading for endurance,
what he gotta do,
run,
swim,
bike,
some kind of metcon.
I liked the metcon personally for my,
for my cardiovascular endurance and recovery and whatnot,
you know,
so yes,
you can,
you can add running and sprinting into those.
You can sprint swimming,
you can sprint on a bike,
you can use kettle bells to work your met come scenario.
You can actually use barbells to do metcons,
you know,
do a bunch of cleans and you will get tired.
And uh,
and then with that,
when you work on your insurance,
that thereby improves your recovery.
And so that's,
that's going to help you there.
Then you have agility and for agility.
What do you do to some sports?
Some,
some cross training of sports.
I personally like to surf.
Um,
but you know,
it's not just that it's basketball,
it's go play soccer,
go Haka,
baseball,
whatever set you work on your agility.
Then you get your speed.
And I already talked about this.
You got you're running,
you're sprinting and the air bike or whatever
the appropriate reception,
the the gymnastics,
the movement type things,
or you're holding your body in space.
So that's a lot of stuff.
That's a lot of stuff.
And you pile all that together and you got a lot of varied,
varied activity.
And what's nice about that is when people talk about getting burnt out,
I'm like,
well I never get burnt out on working out.
I got 97 different bass exercises that I can use.
I'm not going to get burned out.
So,
and what's fun is you jump into these challenges like or,
or you find something that's challenging that you can't do and you go,
okay,
well I'm going to try and do that.
I'm going to see what I can get my weight up to on this.
I'm going to see if I can do this movement in gymnastics.
I'm going to see if I can do this many pull ups or whatever.
You do keep continually varying and heading in a different direction.
And I think,
I think when you combine all those things together and you become a well rounded
athlete,
that is what will help you the most with the Jujitsu well,
but I don't think there's one exercise like hey this will help you in Jujitsu.
Although the clean and jerk is pretty good.
Yeah.
Anything with like your body weight.
So cause like in Judith that when you're doing Jujitsu that's mainly what it is.
Sure.
There are elements where you're,
you're trying to control someone else's body with,
but it's mainly what you're doing with your body.
So like when you do,
you know,
you know like
when you climb up oh the pegboard yes.
Yeah.
Like that kind of stuff.
Bars,
all the gymnastic stuff.
Um,
and then as far as
like being strong in these weird ways cause that's essentially what you're going
to be doing.
And you do too,
you know,
there is,
there is though,
there is in Jujitsu you're oftentimes you're moving someone else's way too.
Yeah.
In,
in guys that are super explosive.
Oh that's a different thing to deal with.
And it's,
it's a good trait to have to be super explosive.
Yes,
for sure.
So the,
so you combine that with what I like when you shrimp out the summit,
right?
Yup,
sure.
Something's gonna be trying to holding you,
but when you shrimp,
you're pushing your own body weight,
that's your own body weight of sure.
You add his own,
that's you're with a guy that's just kind of part of the game.
But if you can control your own body in these stronger ways,
that's going to give like such a big benefit.
So,
and then to your Olympic lifting.
To me that's,
in my opinion,
that's
probably one of the best ones.
Olympic.
And this is why not only do you get that little little explosion,
uh,
explosive movements in there,
but when you,
uh,
when you put Olympic lifting,
lifting to make up your metcon,
when you do like a clean,
like a clean and press right,
you,
your muscle work is just for a second.
And then for a second it's almost kind of relaxed and then pull them again and
then it's kind of relaxed and then you hold and boom and it's just repetitive to
you.
That's kind of what you did.
So it can be depending on your game.
Yeah.
So,
and if you're in shape in that way where you can go hard rest for just a little
bit and then go hard again,
if that's kind of,
if you can do that,
if you're in that kind of shape,
that's going to help.
So when you do,
when you do a met Connor circuit training,
something like that where if you can do the exercise dynamic risks,
like active rest,
you know where you were,
you're walking or even jogging kind of.
That's what you do too,
is it's like work and you're,
cause you're never really just laying there,
you know,
do that kind of thing and do it in like rounds.
If,
if you're into like a 10 minute round and you did too and that's really your
thing,
then do your circuit train 10 minute rounds,
you know,
it'll like,
it'll help,
it'll get you kind of aware of like,
okay,
I'm this tired,
they're going to manage,
you know,
all this stuff.
Um,
but yeah,
I agree.
I think metcon,
swimming,
Ooh,
swimming.
Well if you do swimming sprints cause it's like your whole body,
you know,
as you see,
the less the least,
the less comfortable you are in the water,
the more those swimming things are going to be challenging for you.
But Hey,
speaking of Olympic lift,
you know,
do you know mo Mo Wall?
Yeah.
Have you returned with them?
No.
So Molo off if for those of you listening that don't know who moe is,
he's a really incredibly good wrestler.
He wrestled in college and,
and he is a,
he didn't,
he didn't make the Olympic teams but he was like in second,
he almost made the Olympic team but he's a big guy so he's,
you know,
like 205 pounds.
And,
uh,
he is,
he,
I think he is the most explosive person I've ever
trained with when I've trained with some unbelievably,
incredibly explosive people.
And you'll find that if anybody wrestled on a high,
high level,
like if they were,
if they were a high level college wrestler,
well there's a likely chance that they're very explosive.
But yeah,
they're very expressive and mo is explosive to a crazy level.
But the reason that I thought of it when you said Olympic lifts is one time he
was just trying to help you with some take downs and he was the way he was
exploding into him and he was all fired up.
He's like,
you know,
it's like when you do a clean and jerk,
he goes,
this right here is,
is it the beginning of it?
And he's,
you could see that he's developing so much explosiveness.
The first time I ever trained with him,
uh,
Dean Dean,
the,
I can never read dean with,
with,
when he sets me to train with somebody,
he doesn't give me a heads up.
Like if I were going to tell you,
if there was like,
let's say there was a guy that was a really good wrestler and I go,
I go,
hey,
echo train with this guy over,
he's a really good wrestler.
And I might even say how many and say,
hey man,
he's a really good wrestler and he's got a sick guillotine.
So you're like thinking about it,
right?
I'll give you a little heads up,
dean,
just discos.
Hey,
you should train with him.
Right.
That's what Dean does.
And so anyways,
he did tell me on this occasion he goes,
hey mose coming down.
You got to train with him.
He's a really sick wrestler.
And I go,
awesome.
I think to myself,
oh cool.
You know,
I've,
I actually,
for a guy that didn't wrestle in,
in high school,
I have decent takedown defense because I've been defending,
take Dallas for a long time.
He and I utilize Jujitsu,
did if I might take down.
So I'm sprawling and guillotine and going,
going for communalism,
doing active,
aggressive Jujitsu moves to people when they're trying to take me down.
So I'm,
no,
I'm not trying to say I have any major skills there,
but I'm not a slouch to take down.
So I figured,
Hey,
I got a good wrestler.
Cool.
And He,
and he wasn't that experience in Jujitsu,
which tells you,
okay,
cool,
cold,
you know,
you're going to get to in this guy,
this isn't,
you know,
or at least have a good chance,
whatever.
Yeah.
I'm thinking that.
So I meet Mo and a good dude,
you know,
or,
or going over some moves and then it's like time to train and dean's like,
okay,
yeah,
you,
you train with them,
Jocko.
And I go,
okay,
cool.
So you know,
we slap hands and we're doing the,
and Mo was getting ready for a fight,
but we weren't fighting at all.
We were just,
and it just the kind of put in context of them and you say,
Moe's look good wrestler Mo also happens to be
the Bella tour to five or it wasn't even a champ.
He wasn't that this time.
This was before.
This was like as he was getting into MMA.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So he was really actually probably sharper wrestling at this time cause he was
coming out of,
you know,
trying to be on the Olympics and yeah,
he wrestled,
I want to say he wrestled at Oklahoma but anyways,
King Mo is what he's known is king.
And so anyway,
so we slap hands were getting ready,
you know,
we,
we kind of square off and I'm,
I'm,
you know,
okay,
do my thing.
Boom.
He,
he does this take down to me,
his,
his face,
his face hits me in the chest and this is in the less than the blink of an eye
is face hits me in the chest and his hands,
they don't even grab my legs.
They just tap my legs like a double leg and it's a blast double.
And I'm in the air.
I mean,
I mean he's,
he knocked me into the air with his face.
Let's say it a lot,
cause you're huge.
He knocked me into the air with,
with his face.
I,
I fall down to the ground.
And the funny thing was it was,
I got back up immediately.
Like,
he didn't even,
he took me down so fast,
he couldn't even chase me to the ground because I was already,
I was back up really quickly,
but that was the fastest take down that you know,
that I'd felt that is probably the fastest takedown.
Now we have one more guy.
There's a guy coming up right now at the gym,
a nother sick wrestler.
But you know,
he wrestled,
he's a really good wrestler,
a sick rest or collegiate wrestler and all that.
Um,
Taylor,
Taylor Johnson.
So Taylor is another guy who has mutant strength.
He's,
he has mutant strength on normal is not normal.
I was on Taylor and I was going for like a guillotine or I think I was actually
going for a crucifix though.
I was.
So for those of you that don't know what this is,
Taylor picture take picture of guy on all fours on the ground and someone else
is trying to rip their head off.
Okay.
So that's Taylor.
He's on all fours on the ground and I'm trying to guillotine him,
rip his head off with one hand.
He,
he,
he goes up to his knees and lifts me into the air and shop,
puts me through the air onto the ground and is and then gets across side and I
started laughing.
I'm like,
Bro,
you just shot,
put me.
And he didn't even do it from his,
from his hips.
Like he didn't get the strength from his hips.
He got it from his upper torso.
He didn't use his legs at all,
has no legs cause he was on his knees.
And so he just has this massive explosiveness.
But then in the thing that's really scary about Taylor is that he's adapting.
He cause it because just because you're a good wrestler doesn't mean you
automatically adapt well to Jujitsu.
Some people never adapt really well to Jujitsu.
And you can see,
I mean in MMA,
in the UFC,
there's plenty of wrestlers that you look at and you go,
yeah,
that guy never really transitioned into become a comprehensive ground fighter
that was as comfortable on his back as he is all these cross side as he is going
for submissions.
There's some guys that would have been extremely successful but never made
that transition.
But they stay on top ground impound.
Taylor,
if you watch him role you,
you might not even know he was a wrestler until you roll with them and then
you're going to feel that you can't move them.
But if you just watch him rolling,
you'll be like,
oh wow,
he's going for,
you know,
advanced.
You did some moves might away been training for less than a year.
Very surprising with him in regards to that.
Like he look at them,
if you look at him,
you buddy,
okay,
I'm about to roll with this guy.
And then you roll with him,
you're going to be like,
okay,
I'm not surprised at this guys.
Like this guy is strong,
is balanced,
is just like,
like magical balance kind of thing.
Um,
so when you look at,
I mean on the,
on the,
on the surface,
but if you know that he's such an accomplished wrestler,
you would think given his experience you'd think,
okay,
his,
his Jujitsu or even his,
like when he's training his Jujitsu,
you know,
you wouldn't expect it to be that fluid.
Like when I rolled with him I was like,
I thought when you were like,
yeah,
Taylor's,
he's kind of this new guy,
you know,
you,
you haven't rolled with him,
what are,
you should roll with him because you know,
he,
he gives good training is really good.
So what I'm thinking is good,
but I'm thinking this is going to be real wrestling intensive training scenario.
No,
he didn't pull guard but his whole thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was like,
I'm here to train Amir to,
you know,
get good or whatever,
man.
And he's,
and that kind of attitude.
It gets you so good.
And he's hamming.
It wasn't,
he wasn't trying to like,
okay,
another big guy,
let me wrestle this guy.
He was,
we were doing straight up Jujitsu and,
and he's,
he was,
it was clean,
it was good.
But anyways,
he's got that super explosiveness to that's that's mutant level and also his
striking.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
And he hasn't been known ab,
he's just a natural athlete cause he'd been just anyways,
so that's,
I mean we've got a bunch of other pipe fitters to,
I mean,
you got big Andy who's awesome.
Justin,
he's good about Justin Jordan just showed up.
So we've got some,
got some good training.
Yeah.
But back to this deal.
So I was talking to Taylor about,
I go,
bro,
did you ever like Olympic lift?
And he goes,
yeah,
yeah.
I got into crossfit for like a month
and uh,
and that was right before I got into MMA and I was doing pretty good.
And I was like,
oh,
what does that mean?
He's like,
oh,
always.
I could snatch the snatching like 300 e.
I was like,
whoa.
And then invited me to the crossfit games.
He did crossfit for a month and never snatch before and all of a sudden he's
snatching almost 300 pounds.
That's,
that's insane.
Yeah.
So,
but that,
and that's what it feels like when you roll with somebody that has that kind of
explosive strength.
It's a very,
very,
it's,
it's a very good tool to have.
Now there's other,
we could go through the entire list of body types,
strengths and weaknesses because you know,
you get,
you get the lanky people that are strong and why relate to Higgs,
you rolled with heads before,
right?
Nah,
he exists.
Lanky,
wirey skinny.
When he puts a triangle on you,
it starts to cut your body cause he's all,
you know,
uh,
come pre dose like that.
Capri owes us again blank.
Like how can you sweep him when his arm is,
is basing like for like eight feet over there is where he's basing,
so you get that kind of body,
then you get the real small,
like a stocky,
uh,
people with no limbs sticking out.
Right?
Yeah.
You can't,
it's hard to choke him.
So anyways,
we could go through everybody's style,
but in each one of them has an,
has an advantage.
But the thing that's cool about explosiveness is something you can somewhat
trained,
right?
You can somewhat trained now you can't,
you're not going to be able to naturally get as explosive as Mola wall or as
Taylor Johnson,
but you can get stronger,
right?
You can get strong or so,
but,
but the other thing is where can you defeat them?
Where can you,
where can you be better than them?
Maybe you can be more flexible than that.
Maybe you can be faster on a scramble.
Maybe you can be heavier and tighter.
So there's some athletic things that you could try and do,
try and improve to overcome and negate some of their advantages.
Hard to do.
You get some people that are mutants.
Dean's big and flexible,
right?
Dean as being strong.
It's a shockingly flexible.
Glover is so flexible that you know,
you have to negate that in Glover,
you know,
he loves training with big muscle bound guys.
That's his,
that's like an easy day for him.
That's what he likes to,
you know?
That's what,
that's the,
the easiest matchup.
Body style for him is someone that's just super,
super strong and muscle bound.
Yeah.
And that you get,
it's like,
and I'd say that's kind of,
that's kind of a good way of putting it mute.
And like Taylor where he has a wrestling background so he's no stranger to like
functioning while he's tired,
you know?
So I would say if you're big,
explosive,
strong or whatever,
typically your endurance is not that good typically.
So if you get all those factors and they're flexible and stuff and they have
endurance,
there's your bad day right there.
If this guy has that.
Other than that,
if you take one or two different attributes,
you can always find,
it's like rock,
paper,
scissors.
You can always find one that can,
if you just employ this strategy,
it'll give you more of an advantage.
And,
and cause I always like to tie this together to leadership.
So it's the same thing with leadership and what,
because people will ask me all the time or are leaders born or made or you know,
can you,
can you develop a leader?
Everybody is born with certain leadership characteristics.
It's just like a video game where they rank your strength and your intelligence
and your agility and all this stuff that we just talked about.
People have that further leadership capability as well,
right?
Are they articulate?
You know,
because that's some people articulate and that as a good advantage to have.
Can you read people well?
Well that's another thing that some people are naturally good at.
Can you simplify things?
That's a talent that some people have.
Now you could go on this list,
but what you find is that people,
some
are are gifted and they have really strong leadership characteristics,
leadership traits.
And that's great.
And then you get some people that don't have those.
And so what are you gonna do to the same thing that I have to do in my Jujitsu
game?
How do you develop those things?
How do you become more articulate?
How do you simplify things?
How do you recognize that you are a person that makes things more complex?
And how do you focus on making things simplified?
So you just go right down the list.
So yes,
you can be born with some natural leadership characteristics,
but if you're not born with them,
how do you develop them?
It's,
it's usually these things aren't that hard to develop either.
You know?
So when you have weaknesses,
identify them.
Be Humble enough to identify them and then see how you can improve upon them.
And although they may never become your staple of your game,
either as a leader or a Jujitsu player or anything else,
they can become that you,
it's not something you have to protect.
It's not something you have to worry about.
Yeah.
You can kind of function in those little regards.
Now you can become functional.
And for instance,
if you're not the most articulate person,
well number one,
you can,
you can study,
you can listen to people speak,
you can record yourself speaking,
you can video yourself so you can practice and become more and more articulate.
And you can,
that means,
oh,
guess what?
I'm not very techie though.
So guess what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to plan more.
Before I go and brief people,
I'm going to go through exactly what I'm gonna say.
I might even rehearse it two times.
Then I'm going to sound articulate.
So you're going to make up for those those problems and that's all you have to
do is figure out how you can,
how you can make up or how you can get rid of or how you can mitigate some of
those weaknesses that you have.
The other thing you could do is you surround yourself with somebody that's super
articulate.
Echo,
you're more [inaudible] than me.
Cool.
I want you to put out the word of the troops.
Boom,
done.
Even though I might be in charge,
I'll say,
all right,
hey,
echo is going to brief this operation over or echo is going to brief this
strategy and then boom,
Mr articulate echo gets up there and does it.
Maybe not the best example,
but that's what you do.
That's how you want to that.
That's how you,
you fill in the holes in your leadership game and the,
by the way,
you'll never have the ability to do that if you're not humble enough to admit
where you have weaknesses and that they're there.
Yeah,
totally true.
And I know you,
you back to the GT three real quick,
I know you were saying all these things kind of with it,
given that really the main thing to train is how much,
you know Jujitsu.
That's really kind of the main,
that is the main thing.
Yeah,
the number one thing.
So that's all it's like I said a given cause the question instrumental stuff for
sure.
So yeah,
so let's say these all these little comparisons like you know the,
the,
to me aside from knowing Jujitsu,
that's the main strength or whatever.
If everyone's even to me the taller
guy has the advantage that to me that's the most effective advantage that I've
seen.
It's interesting that you think that,
yeah,
I don't think I necessarily agree with you.
What a very tall,
very lanky guy will have is a body type that w that you come across the least.
So since you are coming across this body type the least to get the less time you
have the least train against it.
And since you have less training yet so you don't have to react to it.
And by the way,
they constantly work on their strange body style because you are correct in the
fact that the lanky body style
is,
is gives you more moves,
more unique moves than any other body style.
So there's unique mood,
there's more,
more unique moves that only are utilized or can be utilized by a tall,
lanky person.
Then there are then any other body style.
And also you can pretty,
I mean I'm not saying he's seven feet tall,
I'm saying
up to,
yeah,
like six one doesn't do it to me.
Well six one can do it if the president's in beginning of it,
but how like we have stilts appropriately named at the gym and he has,
he's tall and my kid think he's six five but he has really developed the Lanky
guy style that people aren't used to and it's a challenge for anybody.
Yeah.
So still too a good example where in this case where he's little bit different
because still to has the lengthy buddy style,
but he,
he went pretty,
he goes,
he's going pretty hard in that direction where he's missing moves that only he
can be kind of thing.
So that's what,
that's exactly the point I'm making.
Right,
right.
So my,
whereas most normal body styles,
everybody that's,
you know,
five,
three,
two,
you know,
six Oh they all have pretty much the same moves.
Right?
Yeah.
So what I'm talking about,
I'm not talking about them,
I th I think there's that,
but those are the kind of the outliers I think overall.
I mean everyone plays their strengths in one form or another,
but I'm saying just it all things being equal.
So like let's say all three Gracie brothers,
Hodra,
Gracie,
even these guys who were,
who were taught,
these are like six,
three,
six,
four,
five type guys.
We'll take Hodgett for example.
He doesn't really do any kind of crazy.
I am tall,
so I'm,
I can only do this.
True.
No,
he doesn't do that yet.
I was like,
you know,
but his like just a mount for example,
or his arm bar set up from the bottom or from the bottom stuff is just way
harder to deal with because he developed such a good base on top of the fact
that physically he's made for such a good base,
you know?
And he and,
okay.
And here's the thing about tall guys in general,
they're not limited to the moves they can do.
They can do more or less.
Yes.
All of the move.
So like the guy who's five,
three,
two 50 or we'll say five three to 20 and just say five,
eight I'm sure.
Two two 30 whatever.
We'll just say that's
a stocky buff guy.
He's gonna have a hard time doing triangle on guys.
He's on size and his weight division.
He probably the chancellor him.
Yeah.
That's a triangle.
The mark of the game move.
Yes.
You can't do it.
Yeah.
Tall guys don't have that problem.
They can do all the moves,
they can do chokes,
armbars,
whatever.
And he was pretty easy,
you know.
So like I said,
that's why I think and of course the,
the flexible tall,
lanky guys,
they do have that.
But I think we all do,
I think have like our body style,
give us special moves only we can do.
Even if you're shorting stocks,
the list of moves,
the list of special moves that I can do with my body style is like too.
Yeah.
And the lists that stilts can do with his body style is infinite.
Still says two things though he is tall and lanky and he has flexible so that's
like he has doubled it.
But I think the tall has the most in their bucket.
I think they definitely have the most options of moves that other humans can't
do and you know,
but again the main thing is to know the main thing is for sure for sure.
That is the,
that is the amazing thing.
A number.
And then the other part of this question is what was the hardest stage of your
Jujitsu journey?
Me,
I would say the whole thing just in completely different ways.
Like the first part is like,
Dang,
you get tired away too quick.
And guys who you know are way smaller than you weigh,
you know,
whatever they new or are beating you up,
and that kind of thing,
beating you up with no factor whatsoever.
And they're like teaching you,
hey,
this is what you did wrong and you're sitting there all but well,
I mean in my case I was like two 25 when I started and I'm like sitting there
and this little guy,
I don't know if you remember George,
but he um,
he was a little purple belt.
That was,
I was rolling with a lot.
He taught me butterfly guard.
Oh,
Jr yeah.
Yeah.
He's teaching me still.
I'm still seeing there when my big muscles and he's like teaching me stuff so
that can be hard.
I guess I'm getting tired,
but I think,
and then yeah,
you go up blue belt.
In my particular experience,
blue belt was the easiest I think.
Hmm.
Because nothing really was expected of me and blue belts,
a good place at the same time in a way.
Some people,
it's the most frustrating.
But if you're like blue belt,
you're good.
You're,
you're a blue belt.
So people know that you know Jujitsu a little bit,
but you're not expected to tap anybody know.
Yeah.
And if you get tapped out by another blue belt or a purple belt or a brown
bottle of vodka by,
it's no big deal.
You're a blue book and even a white belt taps you and you're like,
yeah.
And you know,
that shouldn't happen.
But yeah,
yeah,
totally.
And yeah,
that you,
and you know how,
you know,
when you learn something from the point of not knowing anything and then you
start to learn,
you learn the most quantity wise at the bottom when you start for sure.
You know,
so,
um,
and that's a philosophical way of putting it.
It's a specific way of putting it.
I think there's some in the mid
levels where your,
where your mind starts to fill up and you start to be able to
really absorb stuff to big giant things.
But in,
as far as DJ,
totally true.
And that's what I mean by like that's a,
that's a way of putting it.
Maybe philosophically,
maybe it's because when you're,
I mean,
quantity wise,
meaning learning the moves in Jujitsu,
you know,
at,
at like black belt,
unless there's these weird special needs that are coming out or whatever,
you know,
all the moves,
all this stuff.
It's now it's about other stuff.
You got to learn other stuff,
timing,
we'll,
you know,
approaches and all this more like interstitial stuff.
But from a blue belt,
you still like there's moves.
You just don't know every blue belt.
Sure.
So you learn a way quicker if you're interested,
you know,
so you're like,
oh,
I have no answer to this guard pass.
I have no answer.
I'm a blue belt.
Literally no answer to this car pass.
Someone can show you,
oh,
this is how you do it.
You just just block the research and you're like,
oh,
I automatically know.
So you just learn more.
So in my experience,
so I didn't think blue belt was very frustrating at all and I didn't spend much
time to move out.
And then when you hit purple belt,
that's when the learning frustration hits because you're good enough and you
kind of have this weird confidence that's developed and then you and you're,
you're doing so well against all these guys and they just,
you just hit that one level up where you can't do nothing against nobody and
you're just there for a long time.
Cause it's almost like you got to switch over to learning different types of
things.
Yeah.
You've got to open your brain up,
open your mind up and open your game up and you got to be vulnerable.
You're not going to learn without making yourself vulnerable from time to time.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
and again,
there's a good parallel here worth learning about leadership.
I think it's the same thing.
You know,
you come into a leadership position for the first time and it doesn't take long
before you're like,
okay I kind of got this.
And that's like your blue belt phase where you,
you start feeling light and then the more people you get to command or the
senior leadership positions you get put into,
or the harder situations you get put into,
you realize that all you got to continue to exercise your mind.
You've got to continue to grow.
You got to continue to try and absorb new information and try new strategies and
tactics and still stick with the fundamentals.
Cause that's,
that's one thing that,
you know,
the,
the fundamentals of Jujitsu,
they're fundamentally the same from white belt to black belt.
And yet there they change and there's times you break those rules and they're
nuanced.
And it's the same thing with being in a leadership position.
The fundamentals don't change.
But then how are those,
how are those fundamental principles nuanced to handle these different
situations?
It's very challenging.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's true.
And Brown belt to me is more the same as purple belt,
but just more like refined,
you know,
so it's,
it's like less of the frustration,
but the frustration becomes like more conscious.
You know what's crazy for me,
and I don't know if this is just,
you know,
when you remember back in the past,
like you forget the bad stuff
of the past.
Sure.
Do you know what I mean?
Doesn't everyone do that?
Depends on the bed,
but yeah.
Yeah.
I mean I know that
set all.
Yeah.
When we were in high school,
everything was great.
Right?
Or Hey,
when we went to college,
everything was great.
Or you know,
in the seal teams you go all you had that deployment was great.
We forget about all the hard stuff on our deployment or any one that was bad or
whatever.
Didn't work out the way you wanted it to.
I don't know if it's that,
but when I talk about the hardest stage of my Jujitsu jury journey,
it's one big blur of fun.
There's nothing where I think back,
wow,
I was frustrated.
The [inaudible].
No Man,
I never had that feeling.
I go home from the gym every time.
Kind of like good,
good day at training,
but that was fun.
That was cool that I learned this or man,
I can't believe I got a copy of that guy.
He's getting good or whatever.
You know,
you just kind of,
I don't have like these,
these hard stages to me.
Maybe I'm just a person that really enjoys it a lot,
I guess.
Yeah.
And I,
and I,
I would say that that's most people.
I think so too.
I think I'm the same boat and you know,
for,
you use the term frustration lot more.
And I've actually,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want to bring this out in the public audience,
but I actually have seen you get frustrated from time to time.
Well those are like really funny way of getting frustrated to ever I then I seen
the same thing with you when,
Oh,
you want me to say?
Okay,
one time you were rolling with Dean and Dean had you,
you know how like dino get ahead of you psychologically and he'll be like,
oh yeah.
And he'll like be baiting you and laughing and stuff and then the more he lasts,
less you left.
So you're getting really mad.
And I remember he was doing this thing where you get stood up and you were like,
you look like you were just tired of what's going on and you're tired of it and
you're turning up the heat.
And Dean who was just like,
okay,
and then he like Lee,
this is what he did.
He leaned against the wall kind of like,
oh you can't take me not him against the wall and you engage or what have you
guys went down and he got you.
I think you got you with arm bar and I remember it was armored because I
remember thinking,
I don't think I've ever seen Jocko get tapped out be with the arm bar.
I can see like a flintlock someone like jumped in con but he got you in the
armor and you were like,
Duh.
You were frustrated on the last,
I was like a,
we could call them micro frustration overall there.
These are like little challenges.
That frustration though.
Is it possible for it to be called frustration?
If it brings me joy,
is it possible?
Because even in the depths of like frustration and I feel good even though I'm
tapped out.
Yeah.
Especially when you can reflect on it and that's why I think you said what or
when you said,
um,
uh,
you forget about the bad things.
You forget about the bad things in a certain kind of discourse.
If you regard that overall discourse as being a good thing,
then you'll start to forget about things and vice versa.
But I never go home and say like,
Oh man,
I can't believe that I couldn't get out of there.
I just couldn't do anything.
At least it's,
I don't remember.
Yeah,
yeah.
Going back,
got to have that feeling of there somewhere.
Yeah.
It has to be.
And really what they are or just the,
the challenges that are specific to certain stages and these are just,
these are real general things that probably apply to it,
you know,
to everybody in one way or another in the stages.
It's the same thing with leadership.
Like most of the time,
even though I've been some situations where I was like,
man,
I didn't do a good job there.
I could done better.
Normally I'm not frustrated where I was working for somebody that wasn't letting
me do what I wanted to do and I had more maneuvering to do to get where I needed
to be.
Didn't get frustrated.
Enjoy that game I the game.
Yeah.
Micro frustrations.
They're like micro tears in your muscle.
You feel them but they're offered like benefit for overall make you stronger in
the long run.
They're not injuries.
Awesome.
Next question.
Jocko.
You've talked about how getting into into adversarial relationships is
pointless,
but people always get into adversarial relationships with me.
I've been told I'm scary before but never understood why.
My question is how do I maneuver on this without acting like a little weakling
bitch for lack of a better term,
to appear less threatening.
Do I just accept that I rubbed people the wrong way?
So this is a question and I'll do my best to answer cause it's time for
definitely time for some self awareness here for the individual asking this
question.
It sounds like you are,
you know,
a big abrasive person that is aggressive and intimidates people.
And I know what it's like to be that person because I could be,
I could come across as intimidating.
I know that,
um,
I can definitely come across as aggressive.
I can be aggressive,
I am aggressive in many ways,
abrasive.
I don't know that not necessarily.
MMM.
Um,
categorizes me because I'm very cautious about not being abrasive because if I'm
being abrasive with people and my building a relationship under making any
progress,
the answer's obviously no.
So something,
the thing is when I hear this type of question,
I,
I think that there's some little bit of insecurity going on here,
right?
Some,
a little bit of,
hey that's not an insult.
That's what I sense.
Cause everyone's got insecurities.
I do.
Everybody does and but,
but the fact that you asked this question,
I'm hoping that that means you want to make some kind of improvement,
right?
Do you want to get better?
And,
you know,
I'm a little worried that you might just be looking for like reinforcement cause
people think jock was big and aggressive.
So if I say I'm big and aggressive,
I'll,
you know,
Jack was just going to say,
Hey,
those people are just scared of you and they don't deserve your mercy or you
don't.
You do.
You use your intimidation factor.
Overrun those people,
right?
That might be what you're looking for,
but you're not going to get that here.
And the reason you're not gonna get that here,
cause that's not going to help you.
It's not going to help you achieve your goals.
And you talk about people being scared of you.
But the fact likely is,
is that you're the one that scared
in,
in you actually said it yourself,
that you don't want to appear to be weak.
You don't want to appear to be a bitch,
right?
That is that feeling.
That's fear.
It's fear of looking weak.
It's fear of looking wrong.
It's fear of failure and it's fear of vulnerability.
And those are,
those are real,
those are real.
And if you're,
you know,
everybody should be feeling those fears.
I at some level,
but you have to overcome those fears.
If you don't,
then how are you ever going to step up if you're,
if you're too afraid to be wrong,
how are you ever going to answer a question?
If you're too afraid to
look weak,
how are you ever going to exposures?
Any weaknesses?
And if you don't expose any weaknesses,
well just build a bunker around yourself and sit in there by herself.
You know?
So as a leader,
we know that up and down the chain of command,
you need to develop relationships,
right?
That's what,
that's what you're supposed to do.
That means you need to communicate with people.
That means you need to talk and you need to listen and you need to develop
trust.
And one of the best ways to develop trust with other people is by exposing some
vulnerability
by Saint Hack on,
I'm not quite sure how to do this,
or hey,
echo,
hey,
can you,
can you help me with this issue I have going on here?
I don't know how to solve it.
That's ways that you build trust and thereby build relationships.
And it's hard to do that because you don't want to look stupid.
You don't want to look weak.
You don't want to admit you don't know something because you want to be Mr.
Strong and know everything
in.
So you're probably putting up a front,
an aggressive front and abrasive front.
It's a wall to keep people intimidated.
And then in your mind you think,
it's not my fault,
it's their fault because they're scared of me.
It's their fault because I'm so intimidating.
So that is not good.
And then you get the,
you're kind of closing statement.
Should you just accept that I rub people the wrong way?
You can.
You can't accept that you rub people the wrong way,
but then you might as well accept right then and there that you're never going
to be a true leader.
That's,
you're never going to build any relationships that you're never going to inspire
anybody.
And you're never going to be the leader of a bad ass unified,
high performing team,
probably not worth it.
And
the the better thing to do
is to humble yourself.
Okay.
Is to open yourself up to the pain and the discomfort of displaying weakness and
error and failure
and
open yourself up to try and be nice to other people
instead of being scared of what's going to happen if you expose yourself,
go ahead and throw it out there.
We act
pleasant to them so they talk to you without fear.
And in doing those things,
you can overcome whatever these insecurities are.
And I don't know what the insecures you have.
It could be any number of things.
Maybe you don't think you're smart as they are.
Maybe you don't think you're as well educated as they are.
Maybe you don't think that they have.
You have the strategic vision that they have,
whatever those insecurities are,
it's all good.
We all got him,
no big deal.
But if you stop hiding them and you own them,
you will become not only a better leader,
but to become a better man.
So
take a breath
and get home
and take another crack at this gig.
You know?
Well,
I think losing your temper is a huge red flag.
Like I've always said,
and always will see huge red flag if you ever lose your temper,
and I'm nothing screaming,
yell.
I'm just saying you're getting mad at displaying that anger.
Well,
what's really,
what's really what's really bad is when people utilize their temper as a tool to
scare and intimidate people.
So they go,
Oh man,
I don't want to say anything to Jocko on this cause you've got to go loses and
loses his temper and his mind go crazy like that.
That's,
that's me using it as a tool,
which is not good because you're not building any relationship,
so you're not getting any input from people.
Okay.
You're,
you're not respected.
By the way.
People might fear you if you have a bad temper,
but they don't respect you.
They're not calling you up and asking you for advice.
They're not wanting you to run their,
their project.
Yeah.
No,
and they're not motivated to do good by you when you're not around.
They are definitely not motivated to do good by you and you're not around it.
In fact,
the only reason they do anything is out of fear.
You.
Whereas if you have a relationship with them,
you could leave for six months and the people that know you and respect you and
care about you and have relating to their still Boston,
they're asked to do the best they can for you.
Yep.
Glad when you come back to yeah.
Yeah.
In,
in a lot of times like we'll get still the adversarial relationship thing,
a way to look at it as it kind of takes both of you to kind of cultivate an
adversarial relationship,
goes,
go through any kind of relationship,
but it's,
well,
no,
yes and no.
It will.
Okay.
So here,
um,
you,
you keep being a dick to me.
We'll see.
And if I just keep being nice to you,
even though you're being a dick to me,
even though we have a job to do what it yes.
All in all of that and we're maintaining the integrity of that.
Um,
but I'm keep being nice to you.
You keep being a dick to me.
I keep being nice to you after a while.
The way that shakes itself out is,
um,
be nice,
you know,
the next person.
Yeah,
no,
well,
here's the thing.
We're still getting the job done and whatever,
but my reason,
my response to you,
if you'd be a dick to me is not be a dick back or defend.
You know,
it's just be nice.
Oh,
you know,
it's a,
where are you going to say it shakes out as it shakes out.
The one guy who's a Dick stands out.
So everyone's been cool.
And when all is said and done,
we're just dealing with one guy is a dick.
So if you,
if,
if you cultivate the adversarial relationship,
it's like,
okay,
you have this competitive situation now to people that you know,
or Dick or guys that are jerks,
which ended up with,
yeah,
and let's say you were a nice guy to begin with.
Don't become a a jerk now.
You know,
it's true.
So,
and I'm say that because a lot of times if you're like,
hey,
people were Cree,
uh,
creating adversarial relationships with me,
you're going to play a part in that relationship.
Yeah.
And,
and the thing with this question,
and you know,
I mean,
even the terminology used,
which,
which is,
you know,
how do I maneuver on this without acting like a little bitch?
Yeah,
yeah.
Literally.
So you gotta figure,
not,
you know,
not the most mature person.
So I'm,
I'm guessing,
hey man,
you're probably 22,
you know,
24 something like that,
or you're having matured a lot and you're 27 but you're still caught in that
enact game.
And I think a lot of times,
you know,
uh,
people when they,
when they meet me or they,
they learn about me or I show up at their business,
they think I'm going to be that guy that's like,
we're going to just come in here and,
and it's,
it's always really cool when people go,
man,
yeah,
I didn't think of that.
It's,
Oh,
you have this approach that we didn't expect.
And I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
and by now most people kind of,
at this stage and echelon front,
and when I show up some work,
people have listened to park as they know where I'm coming from now.
But you know,
two years ago,
you know,
they expected this big sergeant slaughter type thing to go down these folks in a
whip,
these people in shape.
And,
and my guess is that the individual that asks this question was kind of thinking
he would get some moral support from me.
And I'm trying to give them moral support cause I want her to be successful
because I want him to go out and dominate in the world.
But to go out and dominate in the world,
you have to be a a chess player,
not a checkers player.
You gotta,
you gotta think you gotta use the relationships.
You've got to use indirect warfare to go out there and be blunt force trauma and
everybody,
it'll get you,
you know,
it'll get you a quarter of the way there if you're lucky.
And then it'll,
it won't get you the rest of the way.
So just,
just,
it's no big deal,
man.
You're young.
You got some learning to do.
That's awesome.
I wish I would have been smart enough to ask this question when I was a young,
stupid 23 year old.
You got some,
you're thinking,
you recognize that you're in a situation,
so all you gotta do is just,
uh,
just start taking a different approach,
a little bit more of an indirect approach,
a little bit more of an open mind,
a little bit more humility.
Don't worry about looking weak when you,
the people that are scared to look weak are the people that are weak,
right?
The people that are okay being exposed are the people that are strong.
Like I'm totally comfortable in my leadership capabilities.
So when I have an issue,
I'm like,
Hey,
I don't feel comfortable about this.
I'm not worried that somebody's not going to say like,
oh,
well we don't think you can handle this,
that,
no,
no.
I actually,
I know I can.
I've been in worse situations.
So when he got,
yeah.
So if you're paranoid about looking weak,
a means you probably are weak.
If you don't care about being looking weak,
it probably means that you're coming along.
You're doing pretty good.
Solid.
Yeah.
Chick.
So you don't need a hard shell if you have a hardcore,
but you need a hard shell.
If you have a soft core.
Yes.
That is true kind of thing.
Did you just make that up?
Yeah,
but I mean,
I'm not looking at it like,
Dang,
that was deep.
I'm not,
I'm not thinking that.
But that is a true
your statement.
If you're,
if you're fundamentally sound on the internal and the meaningful structure of
your,
of your being,
then your can withstand attacks.
So you don't need to put up a big wall.
Right,
right.
You know,
but if you're fundamentally weak internally and the fundamentals of your,
of your being are weak,
then you need to put up a big wall of protection.
You need to go round and blow up to people.
And
Yeah,
you made me do some weapons out there to really keep them away from guns.
Some heavy.
Yeah.
Nice.
All right,
good.
Next question.
We'd love to hear tips for moving to wake up earlier alarms and not disturbing
your spouse.
Keeping an alert throughout the day.
You know,
when you wake up early this,
these are,
yeah,
these are thing.
So tips for managing the implications around making that change to get up
earlier while keeping the space or the keeping the speed or keeping the peace at
home and work
and working.
You put that work yet.
So Ma,
he then made a typo or he's,
or he's on the inside.
What that is,
is that's the homage to the Portuguese accent.
Yes,
it was.
Well,
no,
it's,
it's a whole march to the fake Portuguese accent.
No,
it's the real one.
Worki anything adding like he like it,
it'll come out.
Oh yeah.
It can be exaggerated though by certain people myself recruited.
Uh,
okay,
so,
so how do wake up in the morning?
Number one,
let's,
let's talk about one important piece of this.
How do you do it without disturbing the spouse?
Because we don't wanna we don't wanna make the spouse angry.
No adversarial relationships with this bus at four 30 to four 30.
So one of the things,
real,
real easy,
one out of the gate get an escalating alarm.
So what that means is it starts off quiet.
Sure.
And it gets louder.
It gets progressively louder.
I am a much lighter sleeper than my wife.
So this is not that big of a deal to me and I can't answer,
but I've,
I've,
I've slept with roommates that one to sleep,
you know,
like in the military,
you got,
you got bunked together or whatever.
So I've dealt with this a little bit,
but it's really no factor.
Did an escalating alarm.
And then when that thing goes off,
um,
you,
you wake up before it gets too loud to wake your spouse,
that should be on your side of the bed so you can make it happen or you can pick
a song that starts off nice and mellow and that kind of builds.
And for a long time,
for this particular reason,
I used to have,
um,
there's a band called the sword and they have a song called Iron Swan.
And it starts off nice and mellow.
And if you don't get up in time,
it's common.
So you got it.
So it's like kind of like a game within the game right there where you got to
beat the clock.
Yes.
You gotta beat the clock.
You've got to get up and turn that thing because otherwise it's an aunt and
then,
and then you're too late.
What is it?
Black Swan?
No Iron Swan.
It's the source.
Yeah.
Cause there's,
there's times in my life where I will put like the ultimate shocker of a tune in
my,
um,
in my playlist that if I need to get up and I need to get up and get on it,
like there's a song called repeat repeat process by 100 demons.
That song will get you out of bed.
He will get you out of bed.
When it kicks in.
It just comes,
it comes in.
It's like,
it's like getting,
it's like an explosion happens in your room and it's a great song by a great
band.
But anyways,
so if,
but in this case you don't want to go with a hundred demons,
you don't want to go with repeat par process.
You want to go with the sword,
iron,
sand or an escalating alarm.
Now once you do that,
you got to have the gear pre staged.
The gear has the morning gear has to be pre-staged.
So we're not in the dress that we're not pulling.
Open drawers are not flipping on lights are not searching for stuff.
No,
we get up,
we walk out of the room.
Yeah,
quietly.
Stealth mode.
Then you get to either the bathroom.
Now if you have the bathroom on sweet,
maybe you have some stuff staged in the other bathroom in the house.
So he just walked right out of the room,
shut the door and you're good.
You made your escape,
you know.
Oh and I'll tell you another thing,
little heads up.
Make sure that you set off your secondary,
I mean that you turn off your secondary and your tertiary alarms.
So if you're like me and you sleep with multiple alarm clocks,
if you leave cause they go off sequentially.
Right.
You know,
you got your first one iPhone,
then you got your second one battery power,
then you've got your third one wind up.
The windup has the gnarly last one with the
right.
Right.
If you leave that thing,
if you forget to shut that thing off before you walk out,
you want to hear about it.
You hear about,
cause now when it goes off,
it's a startle or cause it doesn't go off.
I mean most of the,
you know,
50% of the time I'm up before the alarms,
but,
but if you leave that one on there,
it's a star Adler and then,
then you,
your spouse's waking up in a panic mode because now they don't know where it is.
Then there's effort,
they're being attacked.
It's,
it's,
it's a gnarly situation.
So shut off the secondary and tertiary alarms and then get out of the room and
then,
you know,
maybe even have your toothbrush and your toothpaste staged and another in the
other bathroom or in the kitchen or whatever.
Get your workout gears.
Not in a drawer by the bed where you're pulling that open,
making that racket.
No,
you'd just get up and you leave.
So then,
um,
that's,
that's how you do it.
That's how I do it.
And again,
I have an advantage because my wife is a pretty heavy sleeper.
Um,
she gets mad though when I come home from a trip and late at night,
I do some unpacking in the night.
That can be a little frustrating for her.
But anyways,
that's what you do.
Now,
the next piece of this question was for alertness throughout the day.
What do you do to stay alert throughout the day?
I think one of the things you gotta do is check your diet,
check the Diet,
make sure,
in my opinion,
make sure you're not ingesting a ton of carbohydrates because those are going to
make you tired.
They're going to make you excited or make you fired up for about 20 minutes.
I don't know,
haven't had him in a long
prime for like 20 minutes before you eat them.
Like right when you actually,
that's really what they're for.
Yeah.
Instant energy.
Well,
and they put you to sleep.
So when when you,
when you eat it,
it's basically a really basic sequence is I'm going to do some output.
You know,
in the wild.
I'm going to go hunting and whatever,
you know,
I'm going to gather whatever,
do some output that expended some energy.
I'm going to need some
energy and I'm going to need some rest.
When you get the,
the,
the energy,
carbohydrates,
food in any way,
Serotonin,
all these other chemicals that induce you to go rest,
that's the sequence.
That's the process.
Don't forget about an insulin.
The insulin is going to make you tired too.
So check your diet,
check your diamond.
I just had a guy on Twitter.
Ah Man,
he,
he's,
he's like,
hey man,
I'm tired during the day.
I'm dragging.
I was like,
well,
we'll check your diet.
And he's like,
well,
I think it's okay.
I'm drinking a lot of energy drinks.
No,
not good.
The energy drinks are addictive.
They're tasty,
they're addictive,
and they're filled with sugar most of the time.
So you're going to get a major sugar rush and then you're going to crash.
So you gotta be careful that they also,
you don't want to be on,
on the crazy amount of caffeine all day.
And that's gonna mess up your system as well.
Does the same thing as the sugar,
the caffeine rush and then the crash,
that's the same thing more than sugar.
Yeah.
In,
in,
well,
I'll tell you right now,
people ask me all the time,
they're surprised that I work out without caffeine in the morning.
But I'm telling you,
give it a try.
Yeah.
Because it'll be harder.
Maybe it's harder for you to get out of bed.
Maybe it's harder for you to get ready.
Maybe it's harder for you to get into the gym with no caffeine and maybe it's
harder for you to start your workout with no caffeine.
But once you start the workout,
I don't think it's going to be that big of a deal.
Yeah.
And if it is good,
make your workout harder.
You know,
I don't think it's that big of a deal.
So don't become addicted to the caffeine and that's going to be cause that can
get problematic.
And then,
um,
power nap talked about this before.
If you need to,
you take a little power nap.
You take six to eight minutes,
you set your alarm clock,
you elevate your feet above your heart,
you lay down and you can black out.
If you're really tired,
you six to eight minutes of your field.
Like you feel like a rock star after one of those,
you know,
I agree.
And another thing you can do if you're tired during the day,
no big deal.
Just find a little corner somewhere.
Go Bang some pushups out.
Go Bang out 10 burpees.
Yeah,
yeah.
Get the blood flow.
Just get the blood flowing.
There's no way it's,
it's,
it's physiologically impossible to do burpees and,
and remain tire,
whatever.
Burpees you can tell you since you turned into a physiology major over here
tonight,
if you want to tell me what that does physiologically,
I don't know.
But I do know this.
If you knock out 10 burpees,
it's a small purse,
Paul,
small prescription.
You will not be tired for at least a half an hour.
You're not going to be 10 burpees and then feel tired.
He can't do it.
I can tell you why physiologically endorphins get released or their stuff
adrenaline,
like when you know you're going to do physical activity,
when
you know it,
you have it.
I'm not seen a huge adrenaline rush.
Just a little bit.
We'll get into China and Russia a little bit.
She's still going part of it.
So that's,
those are some tips I guess for alertness throughout the day,
uh,
that I use.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
And for getting out of bed early in the morning.
Hey and by the way,
go to bed earlier at night.
Yeah.
Go to bed earlier at night.
I go to bed usually around 11.
Um,
I don't recommend that.
I don't run.
Recommend going to bed at 11 and getting up at four 30.
No,
I don't recommend that.
I recommend going to bed when you get tired.
Shut your computer off.
Stop looking at the interwebs and go to sleep.
You know what?
Go read an actual book cause that made you tired.
Yeah,
that will make you tie.
That's like the opposite of burpees.
Go read,
go read a book,
you know,
and just sit there and you will get more tired.
Yeah.
Unless like a real exciting or interesting book.
Whoa.
We had some more,
of course,
of course you don't read blood meridian before you go to bed and you're,
cause you're a fast sleeper.
Fast sleeper.
Well you don't need that much sleep,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The no sleep thing that'll get you so quick.
It'll promptly put you into your crash the next day.
Yeah.
I don't know.
You can power through.
Well,
I dunno.
I,
if I can go the next man.
I've even when you had the latest little baby,
you came in here on a couple hours sleep rolled in here ready to record.
You sat here,
you got after it.
Yeah.
It's true.
And there's all these different,
doesn't that make you realize?
Yeah.
It makes you realize how much more you can do.
I think a lot of people,
it's like this,
and I don't want to go into this full subject right now,
but the other day I did a 72 hour fast,
no food for 72 hours.
And there's a bunch of reasons we can talk about it.
Maybe we'll do it on a later podcast.
I will say this though.
What one small thing.
If you go 72 hours without eating it recalibrates your hunger meter because we
just think,
oh,
I haven't had a donut in two hours.
I'm starving.
No,
you're not starving.
You're not even hungry.
Not even close to Hungary.
So recalibrate that thing.
Do a fast.
Even if you just don't eat for 24 hours,
you realize that most of your hunger signals that are coming to your brain are
lies.
And I'm not saying they're lies like,
oh,
don't eat.
But I'm saying you don't need to eat.
And how liberating is it that I was,
I was having so much fun.
I was a,
I was on this fast and I'm just like,
don't even need food.
I don't eat food.
I don't need to eat that.
That's the ultimate control,
right?
What I don't need food fruit is the fruit for fruit is if you're weak,
you know what I mean?
It's that type of,
you get that mentality going in.
Then guess what?
Now you go on a travel day and you go,
Oh man,
I'm going to be in the airport all day today and I don't know what I'm going to
eat.
Don't eat anything.
Yup,
you're capable.
You're too low to keep.
You can go 72 hours.
As a matter of fact,
you can go 30 days without food.
So going three days is not that big of a deal.
It's not even that big of a deal.
I did when I just did this 72 hour fast.
He was just not like I did everything normal.
I went to Jujitsu,
I did worked out,
I did squats and pull ups.
Everything was normal,
everything was normal.
It's not that big crazy deal.
Just we just get so accustomed to to just feed in the machine all the time and
you could have a,
you know,
you got to have a meal every six hours and it's so at our fingertips.
It's so,
but it's also,
this is what I realized.
It's so inconvenient to have to eat all the time.
Oh Man.
You know flack.
You're right.
So it's kind of Nice to just eating.
I know once a day guys have put a big old steak on and get after it.
And yeah,
I mean,
and again I hate,
there's all kinds of people.
There's people that know this is it.
This is one of the reasons I don't like talking about this particular topic,
um,
is cause there's,
there's a lot of people that like study this and know a bunch about this Nepalis
facts.
So if I go and do the research,
well I know the facts too,
but I don't,
I can't not considering quote them.
Right.
I don't have the in depth knowledge that Peter a Tiaa has on fasting.
You know what I mean?
Or Dom D'agostino,
those guys,
their Ph,
they're doctors.
I'm not a doctor.
I'm a knucklehead.
That was,
and another thing is people,
you know.
What did you do to prepare for your fastest cause like I didn't eat.
Yeah,
I was,
I was with life and we were on a trip and we had like a lunch and then we did a
Gig that night and I don't like to eat before I do a gig.
And then after that we stayed up a little bit and did some work and then woke up
in the morning,
had an early flight,
and then I came home and I wanted to train.
So I worked out and I got done with that and I went and did something else.
And next thing I knew was 24 hours like,
Oh,
you know what?
The next day I didn't feel too hungry.
So I was like,
no,
and then just hold on.
So it wasn't no preparation,
just got after it.
Again,
people don't do,
this is anecdotal check with a physician or whatever he got to do.
Don't listen to me.
Yeah.
As far as like a recommendation you should do because you know you are different
and 17 hour fast.
Hey Dee,
I dig it man.
But I think really kind of the point that you're making or one of them anyway I
think is absolutely true.
So you're,
you know,
a lot of it is like habitual hunger,
but it goes beyond just like psychological,
habitual.
It's like physiological.
It's like,
okay,
I'm used to getting food every four hours.
So when the four hour mark comes around physiologically,
your,
your stomach going to be like,
where's my food?
Yeah.
Your mom's and move where?
My food.
And then after a while,
if you're like,
hey,
you don't get food this time,
your songs going,
okay,
sometimes we don't get food.
Yeah.
So let's kind of act right.
You know,
and then when the food comes,
okay,
we'll do that.
When that happened,
the calibration is real though,
because then after I started eating again and then the next day I go,
oh,
I'm,
I'm feeling hungry.
I'm gonna eat something.
I'm actually not hungry.
So why am I eating?
Why am I eating if I'm not hungry?
Yeah.
That's paints in my mind is controlling me,
controlling my mind.
Yeah.
You know,
so,
and that's another thing where,
um,
you're,
there's nothing new,
right?
Your mind is so strong or whatever.
So you can trick yourself into schools for sleep too.
So if you think that you got nine hours sleep,
you'll be
way less tired then.
Okay.
Let's say two people,
exact people,
they're identical twins,
identical life experience,
whatever.
One guy believes the next morning they both got eight hours sleep.
One guy believes he only got four hours sleep and one guy believes he got 10
hours sleep scenario.
Yeah,
but that's how your mind it knows like basically it's your mind accommodating
what it thinks the stimulus is.
So,
so the other twin,
the four hour sleep believer,
he's going to be way more tired and he's going be like,
Dang,
where that Napa,
I was looking for it.
I need or whatever.
Imagine if you woke up every day and you were like,
I only got four hours of sleep and I'm going to crush to exactly right.
I actually believe I work better on less sleep.
How you like them apples.
Exactly,
exactly.
And that's what was going to be my point there where you're like I told you,
I've told you that before.
Yeah.
I've,
I've told Echo before that when we're getting ready to record the podcast,
the day before I record the podcast,
that night,
I like to sleep less like four hours because I feel like it sharpens,
I'll tell you what,
to be quite honest,
when I,
what I think it does,
it,
it brings it,
it brings my emotions a little closer to the surface.
So like you feel like we're co I'm kind of under attack,
so I better wait.
I better like,
pardon up right now.
I better like get my two numbers from that.
It's like,
no,
this is what it is.
I can get more.
Like when I'm reading something,
I'm more focused on it.
I'm more into it,
like actively.
Yeah.
Because I think when I'm well rested,
I'm like,
uh,
like,
like rock solid,
right?
I'm just like,
Oh yeah,
we're not,
when I'm a little,
when I sleep less,
I'm a little bit more exposed.
I'm a little bit more vulnerable.
Right.
Mentally.
And I need that because otherwise I just become very,
mmm mmm.
Detached or become very detached and it's,
it's,
I know.
So I want it when I come in here,
I want to be on though.
I want to be on the fringe a little bit.
Right.
You know what I mean?
That's what I want to be exposed.
I want to be walking in here and be like,
man,
this is going to be,
this is an intense,
this a not a walk in the park today.
This is going to be hard.
So yes,
I want to be stressed a little bit when I come in here.
I couldn't dig it and I feel,
I always feel that way.
Like,
like it's the same thing in Jujitsu.
I feel better when I'm stressed and when I'm a little bit more,
yeah,
a little bit more stressed,
a little bit more tension,
a little bit more pressure on myself.
I want to be there.
They don't want to be there all the time.
And I'll tell you what,
just so everybody knows,
there's some days where I'm tired,
where I'm just tired and I just,
sometimes I just need a power nap so bad.
I'm a call him and I'm literally falling asleep,
you know?
And I hate that.
That's a horrible feeling,
but you know what?
Elevate your feet.
Set her alarm clock for eight minutes,
boom,
you're going to wake up.
Feel like Superman.
It's Kinda like when people hit themselves
before they go lift because it weighed,
you mean they're like slap them.
So No.
Yeah,
for sure.
On the surface it looks like,
oh,
he's getting fired up,
but yeah.
Why is he getting fired up for the exact same reason that you're talking about?
Because if it's like,
oh mom,
I'm getting these things where I got to kind of bounce back from,
right.
I'm under attack.
Adrenaline rush too.
Right,
so physiologic.
It's the same exact sequence right there,
but you're just doing it consciously and instead of slaps it's lack of sleep.
Yes.
Or what have you.
There would go,
that's
the answer in everyone's going to attack me on social media for not sleeping,
not eating and all that.
Yeah.
Well
it.
Hey chocolate.
I appreciate your advice.
I know I should.
I do know I should sleep more.
I do know I should eat,
you know better.
I'm sorry,
but what does that even mean?
Should the word should,
what does that even mean?
You should,
it's,
yeah.
Anyway,
that's the whole night.
A chocolate don't be you anymore.
Well that's true.
Be Different than you.
That's what that,
well,
I actually actually the point out,
what I was going to say earlier is just like what you're saying,
the like you're not citing all this science and making claims about like how
this is going to benefit you or nothing like that.
That's not what you're doing.
It's,
it is anecdotal and I think the point is that if you push yourself through
certain situations and you prove it to yourself that you can function just fine
with,
I don't know,
five hours sleep rather than eight one or two times or,
or whatever,
or however many you know that you can do that.
Like,
you know,
we'd talked about this before where you get kind of dependent,
uncertain things and then to the point where you believe that you can't function
without it.
Whether it be sleep,
whether it be coffee in the morning,
w w you know,
whatever or are eating every four hours.
Like when I was really into like weightlifting and bodybuilding type stuff,
I remember thinking,
man,
I gotta,
I gotta hurry up and eat.
It's four hours or whatever.
And then kind of later on in life and I've got like,
I haven't eaten yet today and it's late in the day.
I'm fine,
you're not,
I'm not losing my,
yeah,
whatever games.
But Games,
game,
whatever.
So once you prove it to yourself,
it's like if you stay up all night when you have work the next day and you do
your work when you go to bed,
you can be like,
hey,
if I had to,
I could do that again.
That is another thing that I enjoy about pushing those envelopes is it feels
really good to go to bed when you've been awake for a long time.
It feels really good to eat a meal once you haven't eaten for him for awhile.
You appreciate it more.
Yeah,
that's good.
That's true.
But that's kind of a psycho wave of invoking appreciation.
My opinion.
Understood.
Mixed question.
Oh,
back to the Iron Swan.
That's it.
That's the song.
Just a reminder to give it a try.
The sword,
this sword.
Next question.
What's the best way to handle awful random
people say bunch of intimidating thugs on a bus or a violence,
scary drunk person.
Well,
when there's even more awful random people out there that you might need to look
out for,
I think this is,
uh,
you know,
obviously you've got people that are pointed criminals that are coming after
you.
You got terrorist that might be coming after you or just trying to do random
acts of mass violence.
So those are,
those are particular type.
I think that this is a question directed for more of,
of something that could easily happen to people.
Random people that are being jerks or thugs or people that are drunk or high or
wouldn't have brought.
Okay.
So obviously what do we want to do?
We want to be prepared.
So to start with,
you want to be in really good physical condition.
So,
I mean,
do you want to work out?
You want to be ready to handle yourself physically.
Um,
you want to know how to fight.
That means you need to train Jujitsu,
boxing,
Moy,
Thai wrestling,
you.
If you're in a high crime area,
you're in a high threat area and you think this stuff is really going to happen
out there,
then guess what?
You need to get a firearm.
You need to learn how to shoot a firearm.
You need to train with the firearm.
You need to understand the ramifications of utilizing a firearm and then you
need to carry it so you can protect yourself.
And those same things go.
If you decide you're going to carry any kind of weapon,
whether it's pepper spray or a mace or an ASP or a knife,
anything that you're going to carry,
you better know what you're doing.
You need to prepare with it.
So that's what you need to do to be prepared.
Okay?
That's,
that's what in,
and you know I've said this before,
I said it on the Sam Harris' podcast.
If you,
you,
if you do these things,
if you work on your physical condition,
if you work on your fighting,
if you work on your shooting,
if you work on your,
your weapon skills and you never have to use them,
great.
I will still say it is not been wasted time.
It has been time that has made you a better person.
It's imposed discipline on you.
It's got you better physical conditioning.
It's just good for you.
So regardless,
you should be training in these types of situations.
Now,
once you get to this type of situation,
first of all,
how did you get there?
Because we need to have situational awareness,
right?
You,
how are you not paying attention to what's going on around you?
You need to pay attention to what's going on around you.
And then you watch for these scenarios that could unfold and you avoid them,
period.
So,
so how are you getting stuck on a bus with a bunch of maniacs,
right?
And he,
there's something when they got on,
you got off.
That's a real simple,
right?
Or you go to get on and you see these knuckleheads.
You Walk Right back off.
I mean that's,
that's pretty easy and all.
There's a bunch of knuckleheads walking down the street towards you.
Cool.
Cross the street,
walk down the other side.
Situational awareness.
Oh you hear him coming up behind you.
Cool.
Step off across the street.
Avoid.
We want to be have situational awareness.
That's going to solve that should solve 99% of your problems is being aware of
your surroundings,
understanding your situation,
planning.
What about just simple planning,
like where you going?
When are you going to come home?
You know,
if you took a subway into the city at night and you know you're going to work,
coming home late at night and you're alone and you are suspect of what's
happening,
maybe you get an Uber instead of riding the subway.
It's just planning that comes into play as well to avoid these situations.
Now if you do get caught in these situations,
here's a couple recommendations.
Okay.
My number one is to kind of do your best to detach from,
from the scenario,
right?
So you got,
let's say you're on a bus and there's a bunch of people acting crazy and they
jumped on right after you got on and you couldn't get oftentimes,
so now you're on the bus with them.
I want you to detach from them,
so that means you're not looking at them,
you're not staring at them,
you're not being all intimidated.
You want to just attach,
just do what you would normally do in your,
everyone carries a phone these days.
Break out your phone,
start looking at your phone,
pull out your paper,
started looking at your paper study.
If you don't have either one of those two,
you know,
look outside,
look at the passing.
Just just don't enter their world.
Don't become a part of their thing that they have going on because what they
want you to do is they want you to make eye contact.
What they want you to do is glance over at them.
What they want you to do is enter their world because a lot of times these
knuckleheads that they're in their own world and you actually have to penetrate
their world.
If you want to get in there so what you want.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm just going to remain,
I'm not going to,
I'm not going to cower though.
There's a difference.
Okay.
Cause if you give the impression of,
you're just like cowering and scared,
well then there,
that's,
that's entering their world and they're going to,
they're going to recognize that.
But if you're just,
hey,
sitting here,
just doing what you'd normally do and it's not a big deal.
You do this all the time.
You don't care about them.
Don't care about me.
Leave me alone.
That's,
that's where I'm going.
Now if for whatever reason I make some kind of eye contact right now,
I made the eye contact of I've entered their world,
I'm going to go ahead and give him just a little head nod,
you know,
just a little,
just a little regular head nod like I would do with you.
And if I saw you on the street,
Hey,
you know,
just a little respectful little head nod and then I'm gonna go right back to
what I was doing and go right back out of their world.
I acknowledged their world.
I'm not going to give a bunch of,
I'm not going to look scared,
but I'm not gonna look aggressive.
I'm just going to be respectful.
That little head nod,
you know,
how for you having a good night,
that's good.
Um,
and then go,
go back to your business again.
I just want to detach from them.
That's my attitude.
It didn't want to detach from them.
And this avoids them saying,
you know,
like if they're looking at you and you don't look back or,
or they're just like bearing down on you,
Hey,
what do you know?
Why don't you,
why are you ignoring me,
your whatever you too cool for me,
or something like that.
So sometimes you get,
you'll look a little head nod.
It's all good.
Um,
if,
if now,
if they do start now,
see I'm escalating this.
So they're escalating it.
So now if they do start to escalate this thing in,
like,
you know,
what are you looking at?
Or one of those things,
it's just,
again,
what you're trying to do is you're trying to deescalate without being appearing
vulnerable,
you know?
So maybe it was just,
you know,
hey,
no issue here.
You know,
just something simple like that.
No,
I'm good.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
Oh,
just riding the bus home.
You know what I mean?
Just real matter of fact.
Just didn't go try and get back,
but you know,
you might want to just even try and,
and,
and connect a little connection instead of,
I'm trying to go home,
cause that might piss some people off because they don't have a home or their
home is a bad place.
So what might be better than saying that?
As,
you know,
I just got done with work now you're just don't work in man.
Right.
Of course you might be dealing with someone.
It doesn't have a job and lost their jobs.
So what I'm saying,
you're,
you're not gonna come up with a grid,
but my point here is just,
you're just going to try and make simple nonconfrontational statements that
don't give them anything to grab onto.
Cause that's what they want.
They want something.
They,
they,
they just want something to grab onto,
you know,
uh,
that's what they're looking for.
So you don't want to let that happen.
Now things can still continue to escalate.
You know,
you get someone that's determined to be a jerk or determined to be hostile or
determined,
be aggressive.
Now I'll tell you that if you train,
then you work out and you do Jujitsu and you have skills.
People know it.
People,
people that are belligerence generally can tell.
Even in a drunken state,
when you square off with someone or you look at someone and they have an
attitude of like,
look,
I do this all the time.
I'm good.
You want to fight?
I'm here.
Not saying that,
but just a look.
And people can tell
if they're real troublemakers,
they can tell.
Now,
sometimes that's not a good thing because that means they're going to do the
challenge,
you know?
So you've gotta watch out for that.
So
I think that that's right.
Even though on the Internet it might tell it,
it might seem like it's telling a different story,
you know,
it's like,
Oh guy confronts the wrong guy.
You know,
Guy Street thug confronts Jujitsu master or something,
and then it shows that they actually fought.
So it kind of seems like,
oh no,
they don't know obviously out there.
But that's rare men and that's why it makes the Internet.
So it's rare.
Typically the,
yeah,
and this is no guarantee,
but I'm just saying,
I could tell even
before I started doing Jujitsu.
Yup.
I could tell if somebody who's ready to rumble,
I have that ready to rumble,
no fight training to a guy who was belligerent to me directly.
Right.
Terry was there,
we were working and all I did was act like I knew,
I didn't know by the way,
act like a new and in front of everybody.
I was like,
Oh hey,
I'm sorry man.
It's my bed,
a little bit bigger than me too.
And he just said,
but I was ready to,
I was ready to do the best fighting I could cause it was,
it was kind of go time at that point he was like,
you know the kind of guy where he's talking and he's like,
yeah man,
I'm from Chicago and he's like rubbing against me in my face.
Not like I want to fight you,
but just like,
like almost like a dog would,
you know,
just and rubbing against me and then whatever,
I,
I made like,
okay,
we're about to fight.
It took on my jacket real quick or whatever.
And um,
and it was like,
all right,
like this,
go.
Just like how you're saying though,
just real matter of fact,
you know,
you do this all the time.
Yup.
And the thing I understand that it is on right now,
understand.
And then the guy,
and he surprisingly,
it's not pricing.
Hey,
hey,
my bad,
my bad bro.
My Dad,
my bad in front of everybody though
rising because people that act like that are are weak and they're insecure and
they're acting on that.
And so when somebody stands up to him and they look at them and think there's
good monarchs actually know how to fight it,
then that's what happens.
And by the way,
when you do train all the time,
you do know how to fly,
then it is matter of fact,
you're like,
yeah,
I'll,
I'll fight you.
Yeah,
hold on.
This feeling,
feeling it's,
it's,
it's a good feeling to know that you can handle yourself now.
Okay,
so now this continues to escalate and you know,
you just try and keep your distance from people.
You don't want to let them get close.
You don't know they got a knife.
You don't know what kind of disease they are used to want to keep away from
them.
But eventually you might not be able to backup anymore.
You might not be able to keep any distance.
Um,
watch their hands,
keep as much distance as you can't.
Eventually you got to put your hands up and kind of a nonconfrontational way to
protect your face to protect those soccer punch.
That's common.
Um,
you know,
you put your hands up just in a non confrontational way,
up,
up around your head and continue to deescalate.
Hey Man,
I'm out here.
Don't,
don't want any problems.
You know,
I'm not looking for an issue.
I don't know what your issue is,
but I don't have any issue with you.
I'm just trying to head home from work.
You know,
one of those things.
And finally,
if you get to a point where you have no choice,
well then you utilize the skills that you have.
You hit hard,
hit fast and don't stop hiding until the threat is neutralized and then you get
away.
And that's in order to be able to do that,
you know,
go to step one,
prepare,
prepare your,
uh,
the 99% of situations will be avoided if you're just aware,
most important thing,
the most important thing,
that's a huge deal.
So true.
We would much rather have you do that because any of these situations I could go
out,
I'm pretty prepared for anything.
I could go out tonight and have some guys square off with me and as I'm getting
ready to fight him,
his buddy cracks me in the head with a,
with a bottle and kills me.
That could happen tonight.
You know,
that could happen at a restaurant tonight.
That could happen.
So what am I going to try and do?
I'm sure to try to avoid it.
The minute you square off with somebody,
you're now,
you're now a target for all his friends.
By the way,
I've been in some bar fights where the idiot that is being belligerent doesn't
have the common sense or it doesn't have the sense that he's surrounded by,
you know,
by my friends and you're just thinking you don't even,
you're doomed.
So luckily the guys that I hang out with a pretty honorable people that aren't
just gonna,
you know,
crush somebody's skull,
but you don't always get,
that's no guarantee.
That's no guarantee.
There's murders every day in America and they're not planned.
All of them.
Seldom are they planned
this guy on Facebook,
I want to say,
I think I always get confused with the name because like a lot of people will be
like,
hey echoes and ask me questions in regards to this podcast.
So I was one of the other podcast,
this podcast,
I don't want to be like,
okay,
he asked me,
but no,
it was a guy asked me like this scenario was,
he was at a,
at a bar or party or something and um,
and guys were being disrespectful to him and his wife or girlfriend or
something.
And then he's like,
I know the high road,
I know the right thing to do,
quote unquote is to,
to,
to be done with it,
you know,
to leave the situation.
But when you leave you feel like a little,
you know,
like you will stout and that's really powerful feeling that you don't want.
So like what do you do men?
How do you,
how do you reconcile it?
Or should I fight or under certain circumstance?
Should I just fight for the honor kind of thing?
Like what's the thing?
And so I've always really looked at it this way,
especially if you're kind of like,
if you have mental can kind of control over the situation where you can be like,
okay,
am I going to fight like fight this guy or what?
So when you choose to engage,
you want to fight the guy,
you're going to say,
you know what,
you said the wrong thing to me and I'm going to square off or to my wife or
whatever,
you know,
so I'm going to choose to square off.
Now all you do,
what you did use,
you took on all the potential results of that.
You took all that on.
Even if you win the fight,
you'd get arrested like everything as opposed to taking on all the potential
results.
Probable,
you know that come with not engaging,
which include going home safe,
your wife's safe,
everybody's safe.
Wake up tomorrow just like you would the other day.
And then compare that to jail.
I'm injured in some way.
Um,
I can't,
you know,
I can function less tomorrow if I didn't make it home tomorrow,
death,
all this stuff.
When you kind of consider the outcomes that you want and the reason you're going
to make one decision over the other.
It kinda,
it comes real clear.
Even though at the time
it's so powerful because you're like,
oh man,
I don't want to what's out in front of everybody or my wife,
you know,
is my honor in front of my wife.
Probably your wife wants you to leave.
Your wife doesn't want you to be like,
oh,
my husband got in a bar fight.
Woo.
Like,
I'm so proud of him.
You know,
know your kids are like,
I'm glad you're home,
dad.
You don't let it out of the hospital.
That's another thing that comes with,
I think with training all the time is we all know where we stand.
Yeah.
Like I mean if the,
if there's a person that's going to beat me in a bar fight,
I know him.
Like he,
it's a famous fighter.
It's a famous Jujitsu player.
It's someone that is a known public figure that is known for fighting you.
That's like,
who's going to give,
if it's a civilian that doesn't train,
I mean they don't,
they're not going to stand a chance for their friends jump in.
Of course you're,
you're going to have some issues,
but yes.
Yes.
The,
uh,
the best thing to do is avoid,
but does your wife,
when your wife knows that you train every day,
that you get after it every day,
that you're physically fit,
physically strong,
and knows that you could destroy that person?
Does she look down on you when you walk out of there?
No.
She's like,
well,
I'm glad I married an actual man instead of an idiot.
Right.
And it's not,
did that big of a deal to be like,
hey bro,
if you want to fight here,
come to this gym.
I'll be there tomorrow at 10 o'clock but I'm not going to fight out here and get
arrested.
But you know,
we're in sued by you after,
after I put you to sleep and then I make it so you can't use your arms anymore.
Forever.
Yeah.
And even that.
I mean really,
let's really admitted even doing that like,
hey,
you want to fight?
I do want to fight you.
Right?
But I,
you know,
I'm a smart fighter,
so even that little boy,
that's true.
Exactly.
As far as moves go,
although,
hey look,
I'm not,
if someone does that and posted on the internet or something like that or comes,
come on,
let's face it.
We all want to see that.
Oh,
part of us wants to see that.
You know,
you'll see the bully get beat up.
It's pretty common.
But really at the end of the day,
that's not the decision.
The decision,
isn't it?
Because it goes back when I said that earlier question,
if you're secure in your manhood,
there's not that big of a deal to go,
dude,
you're drunk and carry on.
I'm out of here with my wife.
We're going to go back to our house and carry on with our lives.
Like normal people.
You can find another person to get an a drunk fight with and ended up in jail.
Let me ask you this.
You can be honest,
even as a full grown secure man,
if you found yourself in that scenario
and you're like,
no,
me and my wife,
we're going to go home.
They're still a small party of course.
Well,
especially when you enjoy fighting.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
When fighting is fun and actually,
you know,
um,
one of the guys at the gym who's a
brown belt,
Mike,
he hasn't trained much when you're there.
Anyways,
Mike Dude,
he's,
he usually goes in the morning.
Yeah.
He's usually there.
But anyway,
anyways,
um,
he had somebody like say something to you know,
uh,
somebody,
somebody like smacked his girlfriend's ass.
Like what?
Like he brought his girlfriend who into the bar and he does more tie of course,
and he did,
you just declare him,
he's a bad ass dude.
Um,
he walks into the bar and this guy just straight up just Bam,
slaps his girlfriend's ass and he like turned around boom.
One,
two to the head drop.
The guy needed the face out.
It was like,
Yep,
boom,
got arrested.
He paid $8,000 or something and did like 72 hours in jail.
I mean,
it was,
it was legit,
like Andy and he,
and he talks about it.
I mean,
just to show you like a different way.
And that's why I like his attitude,
you know,
I talked to him about and he's like,
yeah,
you know,
the guy crossed the line and then I had to put them down and it was like,
yeah,
okay.
Yeah.
And,
and that's,
that's an awesome story by the way.
It gives me like a,
for real,
like Mike,
you're the man,
but let's face it though,
that wasn't the right move as far as before you do it.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're right,
because we don't know what could have happened.
We know what the actual outcome was and it was like $8,000,
you know,
and his wife,
girlfriend,
just his girlfriend don't know,
mess with bikes,
girl,
man.
Well,
I'm just saying if you have a wife and then on top of that,
if you have like a kid,
the $8,000 seems more detrimental.
Yeah,
that's true.
Um,
but you know,
so I'm saying this is why you treat people with respect.
Yeah.
You know,
cause otherwise you never know who you're messing with.
And Mike doesn't look like he's a big intimidating guy by any chance.
What does he weigh?
One 70.
I'm thinking of a different guy.
I realize it,
but,
um,
what,
what Mike's one 70.
He's tough.
He's a tough bastard too.
I mean,
on the Mat.
He's tough,
but he's,
he's like one 70 and you know what?
He's a brown belt in Jujitsu.
Really good with the Geek.
Andy wrestled like he wrestling high school,
so yeah.
Any,
any train boy.
So he's just a tough dude.
Yeah.
And you don't know who you're messing with and boom.
But the interesting thing is,
and you know this,
I know this,
when you make eye contact with another person in a situation like that,
you already know if they train or not.
You know,
you're like,
oh,
this got trains for sure.
I'm in for it.
You know,
is going to be,
it's going to be on,
you know,
that's awareness from the training,
but still
awesome story.
Don't do that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
Don't do what Mike did
Mike,
keep it up though.
Just kidding.
No,
Mike,
don't do it again.
Yeah,
don't mess with my ex girl.
Jocko,
were you very disciplined as a kid
and was there a set day or moment when you saw how important discipline was and
decided to do it?
Well,
as a kid,
I think I was,
for the most part,
a kid
I was not.
So I'm extremely disciplined kid.
I was,
I
was pretty stubborn when it came to certain things,
which may be some kind of in early immature form of discipline you have just
being hard headed.
But I think as I got older,
I saw the first thing I remember along these lines is seeing a lack of
discipline around me.
I didn't identify it as people having discipline.
I saw like a lack of discipline.
It's all weakness.
I saw drugs,
I saw alcohol,
I saw laziness
and I,
I started to get after it a little bit,
right.
A little bit,
a little tiny bit.
But there was no role models.
There was no internet,
there was no guidance.
And I didn't have the sense to,
to go to the library and find Bob Hoffman's book,
how to be happy,
healthy and strong.
Like I didn't know to do.
I know it makes sense to do that.
And so we did some basic things,
you know what I mean?
Some pushups,
you know,
if the Po push up workouts that I did when I was 13 years old are laughable.
Laughable.
I mean I think if I did,
you know,
a set of 50 pushups,
I was corn or you know,
boom,
I'm the man,
right?
You are the men 13 yeah.
And,
and we did some silly little like kind of Barbell dumbbell circuit training kind
of thing.
Now I always liked the military.
I recognize that as a some kind of a trade of discipline in there.
And I looked up to military veterans,
I knew one Marine Corps drill instructor
and if you know anything about Marine Corps drill instructors,
so now we're talking 85 86 87 there wasn't any wars going on.
But you know,
when you're a kid you're just like,
oh he's a Marine Corps drill instructor.
He fit the part,
he was just perfect Marine Corps boat drill instructor,
which most Marine Corps drill instructors are pretty damn perfect kits.
Incredibly,
incredibly honed s job that's very well choreographed and very and very
structured.
And it's a,
it's a very fine,
um,
real tight,
real tight.
It's a real tight situation if you're getting Marine Corps drill instructor.
And I knew one right when I was a kid and I just looked at it,
he was like a God,
right?
This guy is a marine corps are,
and of course he hadn't,
I think he had like a 68 Camaro,
so had a muscle car.
So you'll,
he was Josie ope,
like just the man.
And so now,
so I got that going on.
And then,
then there was the hardcore bands that I started listening to and they seem to
have some kind of,
it was something there,
right?
I recognized something there.
I recognize something with black flag.
I recognize something with bank called slap shot.
I recognize something with the Cro mags.
And I saw there was something in there and I,
and I,
I did,
I couldn't,
I can't,
I didn't know what it was,
but it was some kind of strength,
right.
Some kind of discipline was in there.
I,
I didn't put it all together though and there was no sort of unified way to go
down this path.
It didn't,
I didn't find that.
And I don't know if I found it,
if it,
what it would've looked like to me,
you know,
maybe you could say that that path was the boy scouts.
The boy scouts are a disciplined group of individuals that learn how to hike and
hunt.
And I mean,
so was that it?
I don't know.
I,
maybe I didn't identify that or I didn't have the right personality cause I was
kind of nonconformist right.
A little bit,
you know,
a little bit of a rebel.
So I didn't put it all together.
Um,
and I had some little flashes of like being hardcore with some of the things I
did that would it be like kind of getting after some really minor ways,
some,
some minimalistic level of discipline.
But it wasn't until I started training in earnest to join the navy that I
started to what we could recognize now as getting after it a little bit.
You know,
it's,
and again,
it's nothing compared to what people do now,
what definitely not.
But you know,
now we're talking 1989 I was running through marshes and being covered in mud
and I was swimming in the ocean and I was doing pull ups and push ups and dips
and sit ups.
And again,
it's nothing compared to what I do now or even what everybody does now.
But I was doing what I could with what I knew at the time.
And I didn't really have any idea of what I,
or really what people in general were capable of.
Like I just didn't know.
I didn't know.
I never would have thought a good pullup workout is 500 to a thousand pumps.
I wouldn't have thought that,
you know,
for me,
I do three sets and pull ups and I was going to the,
or,
you know,
so I just,
I just didn't,
didn't know.
And
I guess,
I guess you could say I didn't even have,
I didn't know to even explore those,
those outer limits of what I was capable of,
you know,
which is a bummer.
Um,
no,
I don't say you got to remember,
I didn't even know another person that did pull ups.
Like we'll be there.
There's,
there wasn't like pull up bars around.
There wasn't,
uh,
you know,
I'm out in the woods somewhere in the woods in New England.
There's no pull.
There's people,
people aren't like,
hey,
how many pull ups can do?
I never heard that question.
And I didn't know anybody that swam in the open ocean.
I didn't know anybody that did push up workouts.
Right.
I Dunno,
I was just in the sticks.
And so when I joined the military,
I was a blank slate,
really for all practical purposes.
And it was really easy.
They say,
you do this,
this is what you do.
And you get advanced,
the switch to do,
to be ready.
This is what you do.
And I realized very quickly that the harder you worked,
the more disciplined you were,
the easier your life was.
The easier your job was,
easier day was the ease of your physical activities would get.
And when I got into the teams
and really going through buds when you're going through buds and when I finally
met guys that we're going to buds and we started doing a hundred pull ups and we
started doing 150 poles.
So we started doing 200 pushups,
a workout and then it was like,
Oh wow,
you can do a lot of stuff that was getting ready to go to buds and you go to
buds and I,
you know,
you realize that you,
that people,
it's not just this individual like um,
spiritual awakening.
Like no,
you just realize,
hey,
you can do a lot of pullups people can,
it's not that big of a deal.
And everybody knows you can find that out on the,
you don't need to go to buds to figure that out.
You can figure that out.
Just I'm telling you right now,
you know what I mean?
And all you need is to have that knowledge.
But I continued to realize that being disciplined,
all these things,
waking up earlier and working hard and training hard and keeping your gear
squared away and studying the material that we were supposed to know,
I realized that that work,
that discipline made life easier and it made us freer,
made me freer.
And the more time I spent in the teams,
the more this came in bedded in my head,
and not only as an individual did I realize this,
but I realized this very quickly.
We're not very quickly,
but as soon as I started moving into leadership positions,
I realized that the more disciplined a squad was over,
the more disciplined to put Tim in was the better that squatter of that platoon
was going to be.
And
that's kind of where the evolution,
the evolution of it.
Yeah,
man,
it's that whole
process that I'm finally,
I don't want to say finally,
but right now it's starting to become clear where the whole,
you know you're going to pay the price in at some point you're going to pay the
price for your actions.
So if you're going to prepare,
like let's say I'm going to get in shape,
right?
You committing to working out every day,
that's you paying a certain price and the like this didn't having the discipline
to do it,
you're going to pay the price.
We can early is not comfortable working on hard every day.
It's not comfortable.
You're going to pay a little price rate there the next day or the F,
you know,
in regards to the results of that workout,
you're not paying the price,
you're reaping kind of rewards.
Right.
Or you can not pay the price early with the workout and stuff,
but you still got it.
That tab is still outstanding.
So when you do,
yeah,
so when it comes results time there,
that's,
that's when you're going to pay your little price there,
your body,
your health,
whatever.
At some point you're going to have to pay a price.
Pay Now or pay later.
Yeah.
Mansell and pay now.
Pay Now you get way more benefit because like no one remembers.
Well we do.
Some of us do.
We,
I don't remember and take pleasure and remembering the time.
I skipped that workout because I wasn't feeling like doing it,
you know,
like that doesn't provide a sense of pleasure in my life to think back on those
days,
you know?
Yeah.
It's not good.
And at the same time,
when I think of like the detriment of doing the workout when I didn't feel like
it,
that doesn't,
that's not a bad memory to me.
You know,
when I do think back of like an,
or think even now if like the result of being in better shape than the,
you know,
the average person or we're going,
did you do so not gassing or whatever,
bringing in all the groceries at one time,
let's face it.
That's something
that is a sense of pleasure that I have the freedom to be able to do that one I
want,
I want,
you know,
yeah.
You know,
what else is interesting about this,
and sometimes I hear this,
um,
and you did this a couple times tonight,
right?
People go,
well yeah,
but your Jocko like as if I'm,
as if I'm not a normal person,
but you're not.
But I'm saying like,
you know her,
I just kind of went through like the story and it paints a pretty clear picture
that I'm a pretty normal person.
Yeah.
Right.
It's pretty normal.
But I made decisions along the way that maybe weren't normal and that may be
open the doors to being a little bit,
not normal.
Yeah.
But there are choices that you can make.
So,
so I'll have this with my kids too,
or you know who else?
Sometimes I'll have them.
I would have friends,
we'll say that would say,
you know,
well,
yeah,
you're,
that's you.
You know,
like I'd say no.
If you want to win this fight,
for instance,
you want to win this fight,
man,
you gotta,
you gotta do this,
you got to get after this,
you got 80 be like,
well,
you know,
it's not that easy.
And that's,
that's what you would do,
but you're,
you're,
you in.
That's,
you know,
it's almost like,
yeah,
it's unachievable.
Nothing applied.
And my kids will say that to me.
You know,
my kids.
And I think it's actually a pretty big detriment that they think that I'm not
that,
oh,
I do it,
but,
but that's because I'm me and I'm the,
no,
it's not true.
It's not true.
And so,
you know,
occasionally I have,
I hear people say that and I go,
man,
this isn't like,
I guess it's kind of like what we were talking about the other day with someone
saying,
oh that's a good picture you took kind of camera.
Did you use,
well it's kind of like that.
I'm like,
you know,
oh I wake up early.
It doesn't,
it's not just because I just get fit or I work out a lot.
Oh,
did cause you're super motivated,
right?
Gifted and born motivated,
No,
actually I'm a person and I grew up no person.
Yeah.
And so,
but it makes it very clear that these are just choices you can make and you can
get half it.
Totally true.
And I would say that it does,
when I say one,
anytime I would say consciously in meaningfully say,
well that's you is if I would be talking about a way of achieving the same
thing,
like you would do it this way.
I would try to do it this way kind of thing.
If I was confident that I could get the results,
you know,
like whatever that is.
But um,
when did I say it today?
What about your sleeping?
Your you,
you can do the four hour sleep and things or so more so than you can do the four
hours sleep and still function.
I meant you're into the four hours,
five hours sleep thing.
Yeah.
Which is cool.
But,
and I realize that there are some genetic points in there,
I believe.
Yeah.
I believe that there are some genetic points in there.
I believe there are some genetic points in,
in everything.
Right.
And I've told you this,
I have one of my daughters who is most similar to me,
both physically and mentally sleeps about the same as I do,
if not less.
One of my other daughters who is most physically and mentally,
well,
physically more like my wife.
She sleeps a lot.
Yeah.
And so there is a gym and my wife sleeps more than I do and so there is a
genetic component to it,
I believe in.
I've read articles and people send me you Twitter articles all the time.
Oh,
you're one of these,
you know,
fast sleepers,
the 2% of the population,
all of this stuff.
And I'm just saying,
okay,
yeah,
that's great.
But then people say,
oh well you just work out every day because you're super motivated or you just
train Jujitsu all the time because you're just super motivated.
It's like,
oh,
okay.
Right.
Yeah.
Well you know what?
Great.
Great,
great.
Yeah,
I think you're absolutely correct.
And even with the sleeping thing that is like,
because ultimately,
yeah,
if you don't have to sleep as much as the next person,
sure.
That's an advantage just because you have more time and that's it.
It's not like,
you know,
someone would,
would be like,
hey,
other than that reason to be like,
it's cooler or it's somehow more beneficial for me to sleep five hours rather
than my normal eight.
Like,
so,
I mean put it this way,
if someone wants to choose to sleep four hours just because you do it,
that's kind of weird.
Yeah.
Now that being said,
what's awesome is there are a bunch of people on,
on the interwebs,
a bunch of bad troopers
that Eh,
have,
are,
are I,
I retweet almost all of these cause people go,
hey,
you know,
I'm,
I lost 32 pounds.
Hey,
I lost 42 pounds.
I did my first squat today with 300 pounds.
So,
and,
and there's no difference in what they were doing before and what they're doing
now fundamentally in their,
in their genes or their,
or their physiology.
What they did is they decided to make these decisions.
They decided that they were going to go out,
they decided they were going to step up their game.
They're gonna decide you're gonna wake up early.
They decided they're going to clean up their diet.
They decided they were going to get after it.
And when they do that,
all of a sudden boom resolve.
And you know what?
You fast forward like six months and people were,
will you just do that because you're super motivated and they'll leave.
They'll be thinking,
no,
I'm not.
I'm,
I'm a person,
you know,
and I choose to get after it.
I recommend you all choose to get after it and I encourage that.
Any,
you know what?
It's not easy.
There's the nagging weakness
that is pulling you down.
Yeah,
and you got to shut that down.
Anything else?
Talk to my friend Anthony about this.
Yesterday
and I always mentioned this case.
So decision making,
right?
We're wired this environment right now,
we're wired to not get after it in our brains were wired for the short term
payoff right now in times of scarcity,
you know,
I don't know if I'm mentioned there,
but you're wired to,
you better get it while you can.
Food mate,
rest,
read everything.
You better get it when you,
when you and your body starts to adapt to that environment because it's been
going on for so long.
So it's like,
man,
if you're tired,
that's your body telling you something.
You've got to get that rest.
You see some food,
some fat,
a lot of calories,
fat,
sugar,
a lot of energy.
Why don't you better get that?
You better eat it now.
Now,
physiologically your like that and mentally you're like that.
You're wired that way.
So my point,
hyperbolic discounting all of that is,
is choosing the short term payoff over the longterm payoff.
Oftentimes when the longterm comes,
you regret your short term payoff decision most of the time,
right?
Yeah.
So it's a spectrum.
You know,
there's some,
some,
some things are more or less detrimental.
So discounting is when you choose that short term payoff,
you can trace,
trace back all your success and failures to making that short term payoff
decision over the longterm payoff.
But here's the thing,
here's my point.
The odds are we,
you say it's,
it's not easy.
This is a fact.
It's not easy because you're not.
Why you have to learn,
you have to be trained out of discounting hypervolemic discount.
You gotta be trained out of it in one way or another.
Whether it's for an,
from somebody,
from your environment you're in.
You know,
like if everyone's,
if,
if everyone's eating healthy around you,
it's very unlikely that you're going to be like,
oh,
this is how you do it.
Okay,
I'm going to not do it.
You know,
it's,
it really unlikely.
So you can get trained by that way.
Bring invite.
But the point is you get,
you have to be trained out of this way of thinking because you're wired for it.
And all it is is the short term pay offers as long term payoff.
Like I said,
you've got to pay that price somewhere.
You might as well pay the price short turn now and get the benefits for the
longterm,
you know,
rather than discount.
But we're wired against it.
So that's why it's not easy,
but it train yourself out of it,
man.
You know how you train yourself out of it.
Do so plan,
get after it,
get after it.
Yeah,
it's true though.
It's absolutely true.
Speaking of instinct,
is it possible to train instinct and can we trust it wholly in fighting and in
leadership?
Well,
first of all instinct is,
is,
is it's like a voice and it's a voice that you can listen to and it's a voice
that you should listen to and you have to get to know your instincts,
right?
You have to get to know him.
You have to know how accurate they are and which ones you should listen to and
which ones you shouldn't listen to.
And it's real like with fighting,
it's very obvious with fighting,
you trained to a point that your instinct knows what to do.
So if someone gets in digging for an under hook on you,
you've you,
you swim to defend that under hook.
If someone gets the under hook,
boom,
you put on the wizard,
right?
Those are just instincts and it's good and it's good to have those instincts.
That's perfect.
Now,
sometimes even in fighting,
your instincts are actually wrong.
And I'll give you a very good example of this is Rohan with a guy by the name of
James Nielsen.
You have your old to James before many,
many,
many Caney.
So James Black belts been training forever.
He's got a different Jujitsu,
a different Jujitsu,
weird Jitsu.
It's weird.
It's different in the f'ing that you have to remember when you're rolling with
James is that your instincts are likely wrong.
It's crazy.
But your instincts are likely wrong.
And I know that that's a blanket statement and it's actually true.
For instance,
he wants you to pass guard and get across side.
He,
he wants you across side,
which is crazy and Jujitsu.
So your instinct to get passes,
guard and get across side and digging deep with your with with head control on
him and having his arm.
He,
that's what he wants you to do because he has a whole series of moves that he
does from there.
Now much like we were talking earlier about a long lanky guy that does moves
that no one's used to James does moves that people are not used to and the moves
that he does capitalize on your instincts.
So for instance,
when you trap his head from across side and you want to put your arm there and
you put it there and that's your instinct.
He wants you to put his arm dark cause he's going to get ahold of it,
trap it,
and he's got a sweep or norm he's going to set up from there.
So that's the thing you have to recognize and you have,
you can't just blanket obey your instincts all the time because sometimes your
instincts are going to be wrong.
That's the way it is.
And it is definitely the same thing in leadership
and
w w when using instincts in leadership,
the first thing that you kind of have to do is you have to become aware of your
instincts and you have to pay attention to them and pay attention to what you're
thinking and paying attention to what your instinct is.
A,
know your instinct,
and then look at the after the post mortem and see if your instinct was correct
or incorrect.
And then you've got to see how often you were right with your instinct and how
often you're instincts were wrong or what's your natural biases are.
For instance,
you've got some people that are there.
Their instinct is to positive,
right?
Oh,
you know,
we'll be able to get this done.
[inaudible]
and how often are you write about getting it done?
And then you got some people that are too negative.
Their instinct is to negative.
Like,
we'll never be able to get this done.
We shouldn't even go.
No,
maybe you're wrong there.
There's some people instinctively
they trust people too much.
Stay,
go,
oh echo,
I know he's going to handle it.
I'm just gonna give him the project and he's going to run with it.
He's got it.
And there's some people that instinctively don't trust enough and they go,
man,
I'm not going to echo sock can be able to handle this.
I got to,
I got to micromanage them.
And so those,
those two,
those are examples of learning what your personal,
instinctive biases are so that you can calibrate them correctly.
And that way you can adjust your biases and you can mitigate their impact and
you can utilize them and give credence to them and understand them and utilize
them to the best of your ability and both leadership and
fighting both of them as the more you do,
the more you pay attention to your instincts,
the better they're both going to both become.
Now,
that being said,
there's another kind of instinct that you need to be on the lookout for it,
and this one is a liar.
This one is a sabbath tour.
Oh,
this one is a back
and like the devil himself,
he's a shape shifter.
He's going to disguise himself and make you think he's got your best interest in
mind,
but he doesn't.
This is the instinct that says you've had enough.
This is the instinct that says you've,
you've,
you've given it your best shot.
You can,
you can stand down,
you can back off.
You can take a knee.
This is the instinct that says you can rest now,
do not listen to that instinct.
Do not listen.
That instinct is a liar and wants to bring you down.
That's the instinct.
That's a defense mechanism.
Wants to give you an out place to run to little little places,
sympathy and amnesty,
a little place of amnesty where everything is forgiven.
We're all these,
these failures can gather together and comfort and drown their sorrows in the
lies and in deception.
And they tell each other
and they'll tell you,
you did the best you could.
No,
they'll say the deck,
the deck,
the deck was stacked against you
and they'll say it's not your fault.
And they'll tell you it's okay to stop.
It's okay to settle.
It's okay to give up.
And that is the instinct you need to fight.
You need to push back to smash into the ground.
Do not take the easy way out
to not give up based on instinct.
If you are forced to stand down to retreat so that you can rebuild and re
attack.
So be it.
But make that decision based on logic,
not on the instinct of surrender and defeat.
And you need to train that instinct,
your instinct,
train it to say,
get up,
go fight on.
And if that is what you become,
if that becomes your fundamental reaction to adversity,
if that becomes your gut instinct,
then
you will overcome just about anything that stands in your bath.
You know,
I think that's
about all I've got for tonight.
So
thanks to
all of you for listening to this podcast and for supporting the podcast.
Then now echo is gonna tell you how to do that in the most efficient way.
Yes,
the most efficient way.
Yes.
Well,
we'll start with an efficient way.
We'll say that anyway.
Amazon,
click through anytime you shop at Amazon,
tried to remember,
go to the website,
click on the Amazon link,
then do your shopping.
Yeah,
and by the way,
it may seem small.
We get a little tiny percentage yet,
but it is true.
Will you add all those little small percentages together?
It provides us with something to help us out with the pod.
It's very supportive.
It may not seem like a big deal,
but as a group,
it's very supportive and it's very helpful.
So,
Yup.
And you don't feel like you're not doing anything.
You are absolutely supporting the vodcast.
Yup,
I agree.
And that is factually true.
Indeed.
A thing to help you with that kind of make it even more,
I guess more official.
It's a cool,
it's a cool little way trooper tool,
Amazon Jocko podcasts,
trooper tool,
chrome extension for Amazon.
Just go on the website.
It will say a little thing.
Trooper took chrome extension,
click on that kind of downloads.
This Lou extension goes on.
Your browser automatically supports the bud cast when you shop through Amazon.
So you don't even have to remember to click through the website.
You don't have to go to the website anymore after that does it automatically and
you got the tool to,
it's pretty cool.
It's a fish and it helps.
Helps,
yeah.
Helps with what we're doing right here.
Yup.
Very much.
Um,
and then of course he got a support yourself.
I think some,
some good supplements,
which is saying a lot because there's,
you know,
there's a lot of not good supplements up there on it.
Supplements the best.
It's like,
it's not even really a debate anymore really.
No,
I don't want to think it's a debate in any given,
like what we're trying to do,
what all of us are trying to do here in the group.
If you're in the game,
isn't it?
There's no room.
Yeah,
so it's not like you're not going to find a power gainer 5,000 chocolate protein
tub of powder.
It's not that.
It's like legit supplements.
Alpha brain nootropics proven.
They got all the literature on there too.
By the way.
Krill oil,
the best quality ecofriendly produce anyway.
It's the best supplements by far on it.com/jocko you can get 10% off,
so you support yourself as well.
Shroom tech.
Yes.
He commended,
highly recommended.
Highly recommended.
I,
I told a story last time about the,
about the Krill oil in joints about my pro se,
bro.
I'm telling you the Krill oil,
even if you don't even realize it,
I didn't even realize it,
but when after a while when you take,
you're like,
man,
it's,
yeah,
that's good.
Good.
I feel,
yeah,
I feel real good.
I'm shroom tech for yeah.
If you're getting after it,
high intensity stuff for you know,
any kind of prolonged period that's going to help you.
Notably,
you feel it.
You
helped,
you utilize like oxygen better in your muscle,
something like that.
I'm not the scientist behind it.
Obviously you can read about it if you want,
but that one's a good one.
Anyway,
check out.
All the supplements are 10% off and they're all legit.
And I don't know if a warrior bar is even a supplement,
but it's a bar.
It's a food.
Yeah,
it's like a food.
It's good though.
Um,
check that one out.
Check that one out.
Rest assured you'll like how it tastes.
Do your shake it up.
That favor that favor.
Yes.
Um,
those ways also some cry.
Subscribe to the podcast on iTunes.
Of course,
if you feel like leaving a review,
don't like hesitate toward,
leave the review.
Just leave the review.
Just do it.
Like,
if you feel like doing it,
you know how you're like,
Eh,
like I could say this about this whatever thing where you're like,
yeah,
and you might say,
well,
those guys aren't going to read it.
No,
I'll read it.
Oh yeah.
And I'm going to take some input and be fired up it.
It's motivating when people are fired up and leaving reviews,
it's connection,
you know?
And it makes me go,
you know what?
I'm going to get the same a little bit harder when he's like,
Dad,
chuck was very articulate.
Makes Jukka want to be even more articulate,
right?
Yes it does.
Indeed.
Amen.
Do that.
And you know,
helps do that actually helps the ratings or something with,
with iTunes when there's more reviews.
So why do we want to have good readings ratings?
So then it gets bumped up.
Why do we want a bumped up some more people?
Let's do it.
Why do we want more people to listen to it?
Because we want more people getting after it.
We want more people to do better.
Yeah.
I want,
I want more people in the game.
Yeah.
I want to get more feedback.
I want to talk to more people.
When I see Brady Lanter at his Jujitsu class saying,
I just got,
after it told me Lou,
he lost 30 pounds,
takes Jujitsu now
that's what we want more of.
That's what I want more.
And I'm assuming you think that's why.
So ultimately it really comes down to that.
Definitely.
I hate to use the word motivated,
but I guess there was no other word.
I am definitely motivated by the people that are making their lives better.
That of the people that are getting better physically by the people that are
getting better mentally that write me an email or send me a note that says,
oh,
had to use some,
had to use some flanking on my boss today.
Got Him.
But that is good to go.
Thousand percent that's what I like to hear
when someone says,
Hey Echo,
can I use your injectables likeness in a thing on my bulletin board for my
students to employee extreme ownership.
Can I do that?
Just the fact that that's a question he wants to ask.
Makes it
just,
just a nursing.
So I talked about today.
I didn't know about getting after it when I was 13 years old.
Imagine somebody being in a classroom and being like,
Hey,
you want to get after it?
Here's what you gotta do.
Here it is.
Here's a couple of guys they're getting after it.
Do you know what?
Why don't you get after it?
13 year old boy,
13 year old girl.
Why don't you make something happen?
You know what?
You know there's people that do 500 pull ups a workout.
They don't do 28 28 doesn't mean anything around here.
Step up your game.
So exposing the world so that people can do better,
do more,
be more.
Go.
Yeah.
If you had more people being less abrasive,
losing their temper lef or less,
um,
exercising extreme ownerships and discipline and all things pursuing freedom,
three discipline,
that is a better place across the board.
You might even go so far as to say unmitigated daily discipline in all things.
Yup.
So that's the ultimate goal.
Also,
subscribe to you too.
If you want.
Let some more videos on there aside from just the podcast video.
Add some more videos on there.
And we have been,
and I think that we,
not you echo,
but we,
the rest of us,
I think we can motivate you more to make more videos.
Cause every time you make a video,
like when you,
when you,
not just a clip of the podcast,
but when you make a legit video,
I'm always idea and I think a lot of people say the same thing and there's
actually a lot of troopers out there that are,
that are making badass video as to who's at Jean Jean Roderick gene router.
I could make some killer videos.
Can we put his videos on the Jocko podcast page?
I think I did a Dang,
I haven't put videos on there in a while,
but um,
yes we can,
we should use,
we will,
we should do that so that everybody can see all the trooper work that goes out
there.
What it does to,
in this small little way where you know,
like,
okay,
you'll say some words,
you'll say [inaudible] [inaudible] say what you say.
And I take it a certain way.
I'm like,
Dang.
That really hit me at resonated with me.
Other people,
other words might hit
them harder or less harder or whatever.
So if people have like video editing skills,
you know,
or they know how to video edit and stuff like that and put tracks and do that
stuff when they put it out,
it's,
it's kind of,
it is a representation of how those words hit them,
you know,
is that like you make a decision to put a certain type of track behind what
you're saying for a reason.
So it's so interesting to see,
Dang,
that's how that hit him,
you know,
in this field,
this feeling is how it hit him and it's like,
Dang,
you kind of get a different dimension of it.
It's cool too,
because for me,
I'm,
I don't hear my words,
my words right.
Then I hear my words with,
with the same thing you were saying,
like the way it's entering their brain because we didn't get your video right.
When you make a video,
it's reflection of what's going on in your mind.
Yeah.
And so like some of those videos that gene made,
I was like,
oh yeah.
Like yeah,
like it's going,
it's taken me inside his head and what appears to be from inside his head,
which is awesome to hear and awesome to see.
You know?
So we,
yeah,
we should get those.
And he had a couple of that one didn't go through the copyrighted material.
I don't know if he took the wrong songs or some,
uh,
it was a bummer.
Some of those were awesome.
Yeah,
that's part of the battle right there I think.
But Hey,
you know,
which,
whichever,
anyways,
what I was going to say is I think the more people that are youtube subscribers,
I think the more motivated that you will personally get.
That's my opinion to make even more bad ass videos.
That's my opinion.
Like you think it might get like a competition who can make the better one?
No,
no,
no.
I,
I don't think that,
I think you're inspired by this video is the same way I am that other people
make.
But I'm saying I think you will just be motivated more.
The more people like that.
You know when you say a video has just been uploaded by Jocko podcast and you
didn't know that it's going to 50,000 people,
it'll be like boom,
click,
boom,
click.
You'll start getting after a little bit more and personally I want you to get
after it more.
The direct approach.
Dig It.
The pros is one,
it was like one of the original ones that someone else we'd fight hate that.
I can't remember like the names of the people did it but it's the one,
it was to
the Pacific soundtrack is one of the original ones.
All skill.
I'll,
I'll admit I was drinking one night just in front of them.
Yeah it was.
Yeah it was all the time.
And you may drink it that made you drink even more.
Drink,
eat some US playing.
I was like Bro,
I'm feeling this so deeply right now.
I played like literally like eight to 12 times just inner rolling Dane.
This is so like,
just cause you see their clips from movies,
there clips from this and it's,
it's a,
it's a Mashup and you know,
the,
the music and here's the thing,
it's not like hard core music.
It's not,
it's just,
it's like,
man,
it's,
it's really good.
Um,
and I think like I said,
that's like such a good to see
not only just your words,
but how someone else hurt them,
interpreted them and put them back out there.
It's awesome.
You're like,
Dang.
It's like a whole nother dimension anyway.
Um,
yes.
I'll get more on the youtube for sure.
I'm already more on the youtube,
but I'll keep it,
I'll keep it up.
I'll do some more.
We'll do some different
top,
let me start making some videos.
Yeah.
Also to support this podcast.
In the event of you being in the mood to support this podcast,
you can get some cool stuff.
I think it's cool@jockostore.com t shirts,
they have multiple layers to him.
Not physically,
psychologically,
philosophically.
They have multiple layers to them.
All of them.
Some Easter eggs too.
I'm sure it's travel mugs and bumper stickers now.
New stuff that's available right now,
well may or may not be available in may be sold out,
but they could be on back order.
You can order it.
Yes.
Um,
new stuff.
Rash guards.
I thought it was for Jujitsu,
but therefore every there for lifting like crossfit especially running is a,
is a good one.
Like bike biking,
basically everything that records,
you know,
spend x Type Shirts are for surfing I think primarily really.
But lifting whatever.
And of course Jujitsu rash guards,
they're called check them out if you like them.
Boom.
Could get one of those or two or whatever it is.
Support and a stickers.
And then did you did sue patches and just patches,
you know,
you can sell them on their iron but you saw him one as well for,
um,
you don't put it on your bag.
What have you,
did you two batches for your [inaudible] that stuff?
New things coming within the next week or two women's tank tops.
I think it actually live pretty soon.
I think so too.
Um,
but yeah,
there it is.
You know,
good support that way.
Yup.
And that's all a awesome,
we appreciate that support.
That is
oh,
cool way,
you know,
to,
to help us out with what we're doing.
Also,
another thing just came out his little something mum.
Well Jocko white tea,
if you want to get some of that.
It's pomegranate and it's somebody,
I don't know where it came from.
I don't know when I started utilizing it,
but I've utilized it for quite some time now.
It's live on Amazon.
It is life.
Go ahead,
get on there,
order it and get your white teal.
And that's what I'm saying,
when you see me drinking in here,
if I'm not drinking it Alpha brain,
I'm drinking white tea and white tea is definitely what I'm drinking during the
show.
So give it a try.
You might dig it.
Um,
it's available on Amazon.
You could probably click through unless you have the trooper tool,
then you can just hit it and get some of that Jocko white tea,
which uh,
we've been like,
you've heard me talking about for a long time now here it so
also,
oh yeah.
By the way,
wrote a book with my brother Leif Babin if you want to check that out.
Actually y'all brought it back onto the bestseller list,
which is awesome and we appreciate it.
Um,
go ahead,
pick up copy if you don't have one.
If you've got people in your life that you want to help them get in the game,
there you go.
Just a little something for you constitute 20 bucks and you get your,
you help somebody they get.
So that's good.
And of course,
a,
if you haven't heard yet,
October 20th and 21st in San Diego,
California,
we're having the extreme ownership muster.
Two days of get some
with life in me live,
going deep on combat leadership on the battlefield,
in business and in life.
Come and get it.
The amount of troopers that are signed up,
it's going to be killer to have everybody together,
all different industries,
companies,
businesses,
firefighters,
police officers,
a whole,
the whole gamut of people that are in leadership positions that want to learn,
that want to share,
that want to get better.
So come on out to the muster extreme ownership,
come and get it.
And as always,
if you want to keep on kind of kicking it with Echo Charles and myself,
we are all up on the interwebs.
Twitter boom.
Instagram.
Yup.
Phase Mckee where their echo is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and
finally
to you first those in uniform military police fire vose of you holding the line,
train hard,
be vigilant,
be aggressive
and be balanced in your approach.
And also to those of you that are out there working and I,
I traveled the country and I spend time with you folks as well.
You folks that are out there working,
that are building,
that are making things from construction workers,
building roads and bridges and buildings to those of you building or
remanufacturing engines or building cars or trucks.
To those of you that are out there building the next generation of technology,
hardware and software.
Yeah,
that's going to make life better.
I meet with you all the time.
I see what you're doing.
The builders,
the makers.
Thank you
for working your ass off to build the world that everything in it
and to all you troopers out there living life,
driving and grinding and doing the work.
Give it everything you got.
Put your head down,
Grit your teeth
and get after it.
Okay,
so
until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.